programming throwdown episode 101 react js with guillermo roush take it away jason hey everybody we are here with the uh ceo of vercell and a co-creator of Next.js, Guillermo Rauch. How are you doing today? Excellent. Thanks for having me. Cool. Cool. Thanks for being here.
Programming Throwdown 第 101 期：与 Guillermo Rauch 聊聊 React.js。Jason，请开始吧。嘿，大家好，我们今天请到了 Vercel 的首席执行官兼 Next.js 的联合创始人 Guillermo Rauch。你今天过得怎么样？非常好，谢谢邀请。太棒了，谢谢你能来。
So I think this is super, super interesting. The only thing I've talked a lot about on this show is for people who want to just get into coding, try to build something where you can interact with it and even better something where other people can interact with it. You know, that's the way the hardest part about getting into coding. This is true if you're listening and you're a high school student, college student, or if you're coming to this from another profession is just keeping motivated. Right. And the best way to stay motivated is to have something you can show someone. And really the best way to do that is with the web. As someone who's rolled out desktop apps,
我觉得这真的非常非常有意思。我在节目中经常提到的一点是，对于那些刚开始接触编程的人，试着去构建一些可以交互的东西，如果能让别人也能与之交互，那就更好了。你知道，这是入门编程最难的部分。如果你正在收听节目，无论你是高中生、大学生，还是从其他行业转行过来，保持动力都是最关键的。没错，保持动力的最好方法就是做出一些能展示给别人看的东西。而实现这一点的最佳途径就是通过 Web。作为一个发布过桌面应用的人，
I can tell you it's a huge nightmare. A little bit easier on mobile, not that much. But on the web, it's beautiful. You can just reserve some space on AWS. If you're a student, it's beautiful. You can just, you know, reserve some space on AWS. If you're a student, it's free. You know, put your site there and other people can interact with it right away. And so, you know, we're here with Guillermo Rauch, who is the creator of Next.js, which is a platform for basically making that whole process, you know, more beautiful and streamlined. And so I think it'd be great for the audience to just
我可以告诉你，那简直是一场噩梦。移动端稍微容易一点，但也有限。但在 Web 上，一切都很美好。你只需要在 AWS 上预留一些空间。如果你是学生，这还是免费的。你知道，把你的网站放上去，别人立刻就能与之交互。所以，我们今天请到了 Next.js 的创始人 Guillermo Rauch，这是一个让整个过程变得更美好、更精简的平台。所以我觉得让听众了解一下……
kind of get a bit of background on if someone comes to you not knowing anything about how front-end dev works, how can you sort of wrap that up for them? Yeah, so that's a good start. Front-end and back-end are kind of the two divisions that we typically make when you think about how a website works. Front-end being the part that your visitors and your users interact with, and back-end being the systems that support that front-end, that are typically more related to reading and writing from databases, talking to other services, talking to other APIs, etc. Next.js is primarily concerned with the front end, and React is primarily concerned with the front end. The big thing about React is when we used to make websites in the past, we didn't have good ways of kind of
……了解一下背景会很有帮助。如果有人完全不懂前端开发是如何运作的，你该如何为他们总结呢？好的，这是一个很好的切入点。当我们思考网站如何运作时，通常会将其分为前端和后端。前端是访客和用户交互的部分，后端则是支持前端的系统，通常更多地涉及数据库的读写、与其他服务通信、调用其他 API 等。Next.js 主要关注前端，React 也主要关注前端。React 的重点在于，过去我们在制作网站时，并没有很好的方法来……
organizing them, kind of having the abstractions for making them work in ways that were very cohesive. So React came out of Facebook open source with this idea of websites and web applications are actually made out of components. That is to me the big breakthrough that React has really come up with. It's this idea that I've called it in the past,
……组织它们，也没有很好的抽象方式让它们以一种非常内聚的方式工作。所以 React 从 Facebook 开源出来，提出了网站和 Web 应用实际上是由组件构成的这一理念。对我来说，这是 React 带来的重大突破。我过去曾把它称为……
Lego blocks for adults. All right. Because as you were saying, when you're starting to create something new, you need building blocks, right? And when you think about front-end development, the building blocks that has emerged with the rise of React is a component.
……成年人的乐高积木。没错。因为正如你所说，当你开始创造新事物时，你需要构建块，对吧？当你思考前端开发时，随着 React 的兴起，出现的构建块就是“组件”。
So anything that you can, it's funny, like the metaphor, like anything you can build with Legos, right? Like you've seen people build all kinds of things, right? From sticking two blocks together to, you know, building amazing machines. And I think of it that way with React as well, because if you're just new to programming you can you know build a blog so before we started the call i was telling you that uh when when we tell people about learning to make a website with next.js we point them to next.js.org learn
所以，任何你能……这很有趣，就像那个比喻一样，任何你能用乐高积木搭建的东西，对吧？就像你见过人们搭建各种各样的东西，从把两块积木拼在一起，到搭建出令人惊叹的机器。我认为 React 也是如此，因为如果你刚接触编程，你可以构建一个博客。在通话开始前我告诉过你，当我们告诉人们如何学习用 Next.js 制作网站时，我们会引导他们去 next.js.org/learn
and that walks you through creating a blog and that blog is built with react components but with our technology what we've seen is that people have really built anything you could imagine so like hulu.com uh their entire marketing website but also their viewer for you know when you're watching a show on hulu online it's all built with next.js and react components so that's awesome it's an an incredible technology for just organizing this universe that is a front-end development workflow. Yeah, one thing that people might not know, I've been getting really, my son's been getting really into Lego. And so I've been watching a lot of Lego videos with him. And when they build these huge Lego structures, like if you go to the theme park, right, and there's these enormous Legogo you know like like refrigerator sized lego things
那上面会引导你创建一个博客，而那个博客就是用 React 组件构建的。但通过我们的技术，我们看到人们确实构建了你能想象到的任何东西。比如 hulu.com，他们整个营销网站，以及当你在线观看节目时的播放器，全都是用 Next.js 和 React 组件构建的。这太棒了，对于组织前端开发工作流这个领域来说，这真是一项不可思议的技术。是的，有一件事人们可能不知道，我儿子最近迷上了乐高。所以我一直在和他一起看很多乐高视频。当他们搭建这些巨大的乐高结构时，比如如果你去主题公园，那里有巨大的乐高模型，你知道，像冰箱那么大的乐高模型……
is that they actually have something similar they have this module structure which is you know a group of legos and they have people kind of just assembling these sort of building blocks and they have other people taking these larger lego pieces these modules and sticking them together usually it's not just done one Lego at a time. And so what you're saying is that React and Next let you do that for the web. Yeah, it really is a good metaphor because what you're describing is effectively what happens when Next.js developers are building really large things, right? I use Next.js also for my own blog, and obviously I just work on it myself.
它们实际上也有类似的东西，它们有这种模块化结构，也就是一组乐高积木。他们有人负责组装这些构建块，还有人负责拿这些更大的乐高部件（即模块）并将它们拼在一起。通常这不仅仅是一个一个地拼乐高。所以你的意思是，React 和 Next 让你能在 Web 上做到这一点。是的，这确实是一个很好的比喻，因为你所描述的正是 Next.js 开发者在构建大型项目时所发生的事情。我也用 Next.js 构建我自己的博客，显然我自己就在上面工作。
I write about different things. I include components sometimes that are more interactive or sophisticated. Like recently I wrote about code golfing and I embedded a code golf demo. So that's like a really nice property of the web. What is code golf? I never heard of this. So code golfing is basically a competition that happens between developers on who can accomplish a certain outcome or a certain output, usually with the fewest number of characters. And since we were on the subject of learning to code, I wrote this blog post about why code golfing is so great. Or in general, little fun competitions are such a great way
我写各种各样的东西。我有时会加入一些更具交互性或更复杂的组件。比如最近我写了关于“代码高尔夫”（code golfing）的文章，并嵌入了一个代码高尔夫演示。这是 Web 的一个非常好的特性。什么是代码高尔夫？我从没听说过。代码高尔夫本质上是开发者之间的一场竞赛，看谁能用最少的字符数实现特定的结果或输出。既然我们谈到了学习编程，我写了那篇关于为什么代码高尔夫如此棒的博文。或者总的来说，小型的趣味竞赛是……
of learning to code and there was this website that i point out called code-golf.io that basically has this remote verification system to make sure that you give them your program with very few headers and they ascertain that you know you're getting to the right output and just like golf you're doing so with the fewest number of strokes right oh that's cool oh now i now i get the metaphor that's awesome yeah um yeah so i wrote about it and um and yeah like i said like my blog is just you know not many components and it's for the purpose of just putting some content online, right. But when you when I think about the teams that we support at larger enterprises, they are doing exactly what you described, they sometimes have what we call the design systems,
……学习编程的一种极好的方式。我提到的那个网站叫 code-golf.io，它基本上有一个远程验证系统，确保你提交的程序代码量极少，并且他们会确认你得到了正确的输出。就像高尔夫一样，你用最少的杆数完成任务，对吧？哦，太酷了，我现在明白这个比喻了，太棒了。是的，所以我写了关于它的文章。正如我所说，我的博客组件不多，目的只是为了把一些内容放到网上。但是，当我想到我们支持的大型企业团队时，他们做的正是你所描述的。他们有时拥有我们所说的“设计系统”，
where their whole point is to build this, not just now Lego bricks, but you know, you could think of it like stacked Lego bricks or more complex shapes that then their team can reuse. So they're building those modules that you were talking about, almost like, you know, supporting them so that, you know, we know that every website is made out by a series of components that are like buttons and forms and header navigations. And so you can sometimes say, okay, I'm going to invest ahead of time in having a team that'll dictate what those reusable larger pieces are. And they'll dictate also a visual design language that not only looks like the brand and, you know, retains the colors that represent the brand or the system, but also work really well. You know, like the thing about the web in contrast to native mobile development is that sometimes it feels like you're always
他们的全部意义在于构建这些东西，现在不仅仅是乐高积木，你可以把它们想象成堆叠的乐高积木或更复杂的形状，然后他们的团队可以重复使用。所以他们正在构建你所说的那些模块，几乎就像是在支持他们，这样我们就知道每个网站都是由一系列组件组成的，比如按钮、表单和页眉导航。所以你有时可以决定，我要提前投入资源，让一个团队来规定那些可重用的更大部件是什么。他们还会规定一套视觉设计语言，不仅看起来符合品牌形象，保留代表品牌或系统的颜色，而且还能很好地工作。你知道，Web 与原生移动开发相比，有时感觉你总是……
starting from a scratch, that you're always starting from an empty canvas, right? Like you start an HTML file and there's nothing there. And you've probably seen this, but like the default style sheet of a web browser is just downright gross. And it's not consistent either. The text flows from end to end of the screen, which I'm not an expert in typography but
……从零开始，总是从一张空白画布开始，对吧？你打开一个 HTML 文件，里面什么都没有。你可能见过这种情况，Web 浏览器的默认样式表简直太糟糕了。而且它也不一致。文本从屏幕的一端流向另一端，虽然我不是排版方面的专家，但……
like and typesetting but like i know that people are not able to read comfortably if text flows from one edge of the screen or the other edge of the screen right so the web has always felt like this heavy lifting in contrast with like you know apple's design guidelines and their built-in component set we're like they've spent you know decades thinking about you know what makes for a great user interface and they give their developers kind of like a lot of pre-existing lego bricks the web and i think for better is is a very um medium where, you know, you're free to publish anything and you're free to build it however you want. But in turn, what happens is teams and people tend to have to build their own component systems so that they have this kind of reusable layer. And that's how they scale their companies and their systems. And it's been a really nice
……排版方面，我知道如果文本从屏幕的一边流向另一边，人们是无法舒适阅读的，对吧？所以 Web 一直让人感觉像是在做重体力活，相比之下，苹果的设计指南和他们内置的组件集，他们花了数十年时间思考什么才是伟大的用户界面，并为开发者提供了很多现成的“乐高积木”。我认为 Web 在某种程度上是一个非常自由的媒介，你可以自由发布任何东西，也可以随心所欲地构建它。但反过来，结果就是团队和个人往往不得不构建自己的组件系统，以便拥有这种可重用层。这就是他们扩展公司和系统的方式。这是一个非常好的……
trend to watch because, you know, at our company, we've built our own design system and we're putting in constraints in there that are very interesting, for example, for accessibility. Like we make sure that our buttons react in certain ways to user input so that they're accessible to people on, you know, screen readers and things of that nature. And components can also make sure, you know, that they have the right font sizes so that, you know, the developer doesn't have to come up with it. They don't have to really decide that every time they build something from scratch. They're like, what is the right font size for this? What is the right amount of padding for this? So this has really all been enabled by React creating this idea of you are, as a front-end developer, your job is to define components.
……趋势，值得关注。因为在我们的公司，我们构建了自己的设计系统，并在其中加入了一些非常有趣的约束，例如为了无障碍访问。我们确保按钮对用户输入做出特定的反应，以便屏幕阅读器用户等群体能够使用它们。组件还可以确保它们具有正确的字体大小，这样开发者就不必每次从零开始构建时都要自己决定。他们不必纠结：这个的正确字体大小是多少？这个的正确内边距是多少？所以这一切确实都是由 React 创造的理念所实现的，即作为前端开发者，你的工作就是定义组件。
And by doing that, they kind of elevated the abstraction bar. Because in the past, when you were programming with JavaScript and you were working on your front-end, you had primitives that were, to put it lightly, too primitive. So if you were working with full stack legacy technology, you were working with templates. And then on the client side, you were working with functions or you were working with classes, and there was really no structure to how you were doing things. So React came in and were like, okay, what you're building is not a function per se.
通过这样做，他们提高了抽象的门槛。因为过去当你用 JavaScript 编程并进行前端工作时，你所拥有的原语（primitives）说得好听点是太原始了。如果你在使用全栈遗留技术，你是在使用模板。而在客户端，你是在使用函数或类，你所做的事情根本没有结构。所以 React 出现了，他们说：好吧，你构建的不是一个函数，也不是一个类，也不是一个模板，而是一个组件。通过这样做，他们确实彻底改变了前端开发。是的，我的意思是，对于 HTML5 来说，这可能有所不同。你可以帮我核实一下。但至少在早期的 HTML 中，你仅限于浏览器提供的标签。所以有按钮标签、输入标签、头部标签、
It's not a class. It's not a template. It's a component. And by doing that, they've really just revolutionized front-end development. Yeah, I mean, I think with, and this might be different with HTML5. You could check me on this. But, you know, at least with early HTML, you were limited to the tags that the browser provided. So there's a button tag, there was an input tag, a head tag,
身体标签、段落标签，但没有日历标签，对吧？所以当你编写 HTML 时，如果你需要插入一个小日历，你必须使用一个叫 div 的标签。然后你以后要做的是给那个 div 一个 ID，写上“我的超棒日历”。然后稍后在 JavaScript 中，你基本上必须用那个日历背后的逻辑来填充那个 div，而这些逻辑将由你确实能访问的所有标签组成。但这会让事情变得非常令人沮丧，因为你最终得到的是一个全是……
a body tag, paragraph tag, but there isn't a calendar tag, right? And so when you're writing your HTML, if you get to the point where you need to drop in a little calendar, you have to use this tag called div. And then what you have to do later on is you give that div an ID, which says, you know, my great calendar. And then later on in JavaScript, you would have to basically fill that div in with with with with, you know, the logic behind that calendar, which is going to be composed of all of those tags that you do have access to. But then that makes things really frustrating because you end up with just a whole HTML file
……全是不同名字的 div 的 HTML 文件。如果能有一个日历标签就好了。这基本上就是 React 背后的前提。是的，是的。而且这样做，顺便说一下，被证明是非常具有挑战性的，因为你所描述的是对网站过去制作方式的一次很好的历史回顾。你提到了“ID”这个词，这就是开发者赋予 HTML 标签生命力的方式。甚至“ID”这个概念本身也是非常局限的……
full of divs with different names. It'd be great if you could just have a calendar tag. And that's basically the premise behind React. Yeah, yeah. And doing so, by the the way proved very challenging right because what you were describing is a great kind of uh historical review of how websites used to be made and you mentioned that word id right and that's kind of the how a developer would approach kind of giving life to an html tag And even the very idea of an ID was very limiting
……就乐高积木的可重用性而言，因为 ID 指向的是一个特定的元素。所以从一开始，你就不是在设计可重用的东西。你不能克隆你的日历并在系统的不同地方使用它，而且它也不是参数化的。这就是为什么我说组件是一个如此伟大的抽象，因为通常发生的情况是：好吧，我有这个 div，这个特定的 div 存在于这个页面上，我要把它转换成一个日历。它将以固定的参数存在。它将是这么大，它将是这么宽，它将是……默认日期将是今天。但明天另一个开发者会说：哦，嘿，我需要那个日历，但我需要它更多地用于选择年龄，我需要它用于其他年份，默认值应该是，我不知道，比如 20 年前。然后他们会说：哦，我能做的最好的事情就是复制粘贴，把日历分叉成两个日历。这真的很乱，想到我们不久前还是那样编程的，真是太疯狂了。是的，没错，可能有些人现在还在那样编程。所以，是的，而且它也……
in terms of the reusability of the Lego bricks because an ID was pointing to a specific element. So from the get-go, you weren't designing something that was reusable. Like you couldn't clone your calendar and use it in different places of the system, and it wasn't parametric. So that's why I was saying that components is such a great abstraction, because typically what would happen is like, okay, I have this div, and this div in particular that
……你知道，这真的不能怪他们，因为正如你所说，Web 是为了超媒体而出现的。它是 Web 在公开邮件列表中被讨论时，历史回顾中非常狭窄的一个子集。当时他们正在讨论早期的标准、新兴标准和早期的 Web 浏览器，人们对增加 Web 的功能有很多抵触，而且这是有充分理由的，因为 Web 的设计者对 Web 应该如何运作有各种有趣的约束。所以我总是指出的一点是，关于在 Web 上添加图像，曾有过一场非常激烈的讨论。这场讨论中，Netscape 的联合创始人 Marc Andreessen 也参与了。你今天可以查到，因为它是一个公开的邮件列表。你可以看到当时人们是如何抵触增加额外跳转到信息传输过程的。
lives in this very page, I'm going to convert it into a calendar. And it's going to exist with fixed parameters. It's going to be this big, it's going to be this fixed parameters it's going to be this big it's going to be this wide it's going to be set you know the default date is going to be today but tomorrow another developer was like oh hey i need that calendar but i need it more for like i know selecting your age and i need it for like uh you know other years and the default should be i don't know like 20 years ago and then they would be like oh i maybe the best thing i can do is copy paste here and fork the calendar into two calendars and like it was really messy and it's crazy to think that you know like that was not that long ago we're programming like that yeah that's right probably some people still program like that so yeah and and it's also not
因为当 Web 被创建时，你会从远程服务器请求一个 HTML 文件，其中包含了你请求的所有信息。这些约束之所以存在，是因为显然当时我们没有很好的互联网连接。所以我们只能利用现有的条件。所以，你知道，你对每一次跳转都感到如履薄冰……
for you know it's not really their fault because you were saying, the web emerged for hypermedia. And it was a specifically a very narrow subset of what historical review when the web was being discussed in this open mailing list and like they were discussing the early you know uh standards and emerging standards and the early web browsers there was a lot of resistance to adding power to the web and and it was for a good reason because there were all these interesting constraints that the designers of the web had for, you know, how well the web should work. So one of the things I always point out is there was a very heated discussion about adding images to the web. And it's a discussion in which Marc Andreessen, the co-founder of Netscape, is involved. You can look it up today because it was a public mailing list. And you can see how there was resistance to adding, in that particular case, an extra hop to the information transfer process.
……就像世界末日一样。是的，我的意思是，每个人都见过这种情况，你得到一个小方块，里面有一个红色的 X，而不是图像。那是因为它没有随 HTML 一起加载。这是关于系统的正确性和性能。但归根结底，自由市场（如果可以这么说的话），因为 Marc Andreessen 正在创建一个新的 Web 浏览器，对吧？他来自硅谷，我想象他会说：Web 本可以做得更多。
Because when the web was created, you would request an HTML file from a remote server, and that contained the entirety of the information that you requested. And the constraints were there because obviously at the time we didn't have good, you know, internet connections. So we're working with what we had. So like, you know, you were sweating every hop,
我们可以有图像，我们可以有视频。未来，人们将进行远程办公和远程医疗，你可以对 Web 有所有这些梦想，但 Web 当时受到了极大的限制。所以这是一个缓慢的过程，但 Web 开始获得越来越多的权力和能力。所以，你知道，这创造了图像标签。但正如你所说，Web 经历了一个将事物添加到标准的过程，所以时至今日，我们实际上仍然没有日历标签。我的意思是，已经 30 年了，通过汗水和泪水，我们添加了像图像标签这样的东西到 HTML 中，但我们仍然没有日历。但是……如果你今天在听节目的人……
like, you know, like it was the end of the world. Yeah, I mean, everyone's seen this, you know, where you get a little square with a red X instead of the image. And that's because it didn't come with HTML. and correctness, and performance of the system. But at the end of the day, the free market, so to speak, because Marc Andreessen was creating a new web browser, right? And he was coming from, I could imagine him in Silicon Valley saying, like, the web could be doing so much more.
……他们会说：哦，我刚刚在线报税了，或者其他什么。那里就有一个计算器。所以你所处理的基本上是 Web 借助 JavaScript 增长其自身组件集的能力，它可以获取所有这些原始的 HTML 标签（如 div）并将它们变成非常具有交互性的组件。在某种程度上，GitHub（通过 npm 和 GitHub 的星标系统）可以让你通过民主实现标准化。所以现在人们的做法是，他们在 Google 上搜索“react.js calendar”，他们会找到一些拥有 10 万个 GitHub 星标的日历组件，然后他们就拿来用，其他人也一样。这创造了一种很好的“共识”，人们现在对日历有了一种潜意识的理解……
We could have images. We could have video. And in the future, people are going to be telecommuting and doing telemedicine and like you could have all these dreams about the web, but the web was super constrained. So it was a slow process, but the web started getting more and more power and more capability. So, you know, that created the image tag. But as you were saying, the web goes through this process of adding things to standards so as we stand today we actually don't have a calendar tag you know i mean like it's been it's been 30 years and through sweat and tears we added things like you know image tag to html but we still don't have a calendar so but but um you know if someone
……因为他们在很多地方都见过类似相同的日历。是的，这种开放系统确实需要更长的时间。开放系统使得我们经历了数代破碎、不可访问、次优的日历，但总有一个持续的迭代过程，辅以你所说的各种评分机制……
is listening today they were like oh i just I just filed my taxes online or whatever. And there was a calculator right there. So that's what you're dealing with is basically the ability for the web to grow its own component set thanks to the help of JavaScript, which can sort of take all this primitive HTML tags like div and turn them into very interactive widgets right and in a way the github uh you know with npm and github and and the github star system you can kind of get a standardization through democracy right so now what people do is they say react.js calendar cycle and github.com they punch that into google they find some calendar uh component that has you know 100 000 github.com they punch that into google they find some calendar uh component that has you know a hundred thousand github stars and they grab that and and so does everybody else and it creates sort of a nice sort of gnosis like people now have this sort of unconscious understanding
……和流行度机制。而且，人们只是想“鞭打那匹还没死透的马”。我见过很多次，我以为 Web 上的某个问题已经解决了，然后我看到有人做得更好。你知道，他们只是把它做得更小，添加了一个我没想到的动画。
of of of the calendar because they've seen the so the same similar calendar so many places. Yeah, and this open system, right, I think takes longer. The open system makes it such that, you know, we've been through generations of broken, inaccessible subpar calendars, but there's always this constant iteration process aided by what you were saying, like all kinds of different scoring mechanism
他们让它在移动端运行得更好。Web 就是这样一个不断迭代的系统。但对于刚入门的人来说，这并不意味着他们必须经历这些。这并不意味着他们必须构建自己的组件。你可以随时从别人制作的组件库中进行选择。比如在 Next.js 世界中，我们知道很多人使用 Material UI，这是 Google 的开源组件系统。它今天就是作为 React 组件分发的。
and popularity mechanisms. And, you know, people just wanting to beat the horse that is not yet sufficiently dead in some ways. Like I've seen so many times that like, I consider a problem to be solved on the web and then I see someone doing it better. You know, like they just make it smaller. They added an animation that, you know, I didn't think of.
还有另一个叫 Ant Design，它来自中国阿里巴巴云。它也非常受欢迎。所以公司也开源了他们整个组件系统，这真的很好。是的，那太棒了。是的，所以也许我们可以谈谈 React 是如何做到这一点的。React 是如何将组件添加到 HTML 的？我觉得那会非常有趣。是的，这超级有趣，因为我总是指出的一点是……
They make it work better on mobile. Like the web is just this constantly iterating system. But for people that are getting started, you know, it doesn't mean that they have to go through that. It doesn't mean that they have to build their own components. So you can always choose from libraries of components that other people have made. Like in the Next.js world, we know a lot of people use Material UI, which is like Google's component system that is open source. And it's being distributed today as React components.
……React 在编程模型上确实具有革命性。当 React 开始时，当 React 的作者向世界展示它时，他们说：看，React 并没有受到之前 JavaScript 库（如 jQuery 等）的太多启发。他们说：听着，这是一个全新的事物。我认为正是因为这种叙事，他们在开始时被轻视了一点，因为很多人会告诉你：坐下，这完全不同，然后你最终会感到失望。但在这种情况下，它是真的。所以 React 并没有受到我们所说的“命令式 DOM 操作库”的太多启发。DOM 是你与 HTML 交互的方式。他们说它更多地受到游戏引擎如何绘制屏幕的启发。这确实是除了引入“组件”（这并不完全是新的，到处都有各种小部件和系统，包括 jQuery UI）之外，真正具有革命性的地方，即你不是在用户做某些事情时给计算机下达具体指令。你总是对计算机说：对于这种世界状态，我希望整个屏幕是这样的……
There's another one called Ant Design that came out of Alibaba Cloud in China. It's very popular as well. So companies have also open sourced their entire component systems, which is really nice. Yeah, that's awesome. Yeah, so maybe just like we could talk a little bit about how React does this. How does React add components to HTML? I think that would be really interesting. Yeah, that's super interesting because one of the things that I always point out that
……几乎是一种从数据到屏幕的映射，开发者不必考虑增量。例如，假设你正在编写一个时钟，对吧？你想渲染时间。我现在在旧金山，处于旧金山时区。时间的原始值，假设它是一个时间戳，是一个整数。
React has been really revolutionary for is the programming model. So when React started, when the authors of React were kind of presenting it to the world, they were saying, look, React hasn't been so much inspired by previous JavaScript libraries, like jQuery and so on. They were saying, listen, this is an altogether new thing. And I think because of that kind of narrative, they were dismissed a little bit in the beginning because you know a lot of people were telling you like sit down this is completely different and then you end up being disappointed right but in this case it was true so react wasn't so much inspired by previous uh what we call imperative dom manipulation libraries so dom is the uh basically the way that you interface
然后我想说，每一秒，我都想更新屏幕，我想渲染格式化为用户时区的当前时间。我正在旧金山，我想以某种方式装饰这个时钟。当我们过去用旧技术在 Web 上编程时，我们使用所有这些命令式代码。例如，我们会说：好吧，这是时间的开始。所以让我们第一次渲染时间。然后我们会把代码放进去。然后我们会创建一个计时器，说：嘿，每一秒，获取那个时间并更新它。所以基本上，编程方式存在这种区别。有一种嵌入在“好吧，这是开始”中的时间概念。
typically between javascript with those html, they said it was more inspired by how game engines paint a screen. And this is really what also, in addition to the introduction of Component, which is not altogether new, and there were all kinds of widgets and widget systems all over the place, including jQuery UI, but what was truly revolutionary was this idea that you're not really giving specific instructions to the computer when the user does certain things. You're always saying to the computer, hey, for this state of the world, I want the entire screen to be like this,
我们像这样绘制它。好吧，现在变化来了。我必须去查看屏幕并做出这个具体的改变。而 React 进来后说：看，你只需要描述屏幕看起来是什么样子。我们会为你处理屏幕的所有更新。我们会处理，例如，如果你注册时间每 N 秒改变一次，而我们必须对屏幕进行操作，我们会做所有这些。你只需要告诉我们，对于这个特定的数据，你希望屏幕看起来是什么样子，以及你想在其中包含哪些组件。
almost like a mapping from data to screen in a way where the developer didn't have to think about the deltas. So for example, say that you're programming a clock, right? And you want the time to be rendered. I'm in San Francisco right now in the time zone of San Francisco. The primitive value of the time, let's say it's a timestamp, it's an integer.
是的，这有点像图形世界、计算机游戏世界。例如，使用纯 OpenGL，你必须说：绘制三角形，等待 1/60 秒，绘制三角形，绘制三角形，绘制三角形，三角形移动，下一次绘制三角形。但如果你使用像 Unity 这样的东西，你只需要说：我有一个三角形，它在 x=3 的位置。然后你可以等待一天、一小时或一分钟，随便。然后说：好吧，现在我的三角形在 x=6 的位置。Unity 负责说：绘制三角形。你只是在说世界看起来是什么样子。
And then I want to say every second, I want to update the screen, and I want to render the time formatted to the time zone of the user, which is, I'm in San Francisco right now, and I want to decorate the clock in some way or another. When we used to program that with old technologies in the web, we used to have all these imperative codes. So for example, we would say, okay, it's the beginning of time. So let's render the time for the first time. Then we would like put in that code. And then we would create a timer that says, hey, every second, take that and update it. So basically there was this distinction in how you would program. There was this idea of time that was being embedded in like, okay, this is the beginning.
你让 Unity 这个游戏引擎来处理绘制。所以 React 对 Web 来说就是那样的。完全正确。我们在 Web 上工作的方式，正如你所描述的，就像访问显卡一样，我们在如此低的层面上工作，以至于我们关心的事情基本上是可以自动化的。我记得当 React 变得非常流行时，很多人把它比作“自动垃圾回收”，从手动操作内存转变为让引擎自动执行。这个比喻非常好，因为最好的例子是，在现代非常复杂的软件程序中，你不仅仅是在处理把三角形从 A 移动到 B，你是在处理用户说：好吧，现在忘了它。我不想尝试，或者我想……
We painted like this. Okay, now changes are coming. I have to go and look at the screen and make this specific change. Whereas React came in and said, look, you're just going to describe what the screen looks like. And we'll handle all the updates to the screen for you we'll handle for example um if you register the time to change uh every n seconds and we have to make a manipulation to the screen we'll do all that you just tell us for this particular data how you want the screen to look like and what components you want to involve in that
……去别的地方。你必须丢弃那个三角形，你需要把它从屏幕上完全清除。如果你想想旧世界以及我们过去是如何编程的，我们会使用所谓的 CSS 选择器。我们会说：嘿，好吧，用户想去别的地方。所以首先让我们清理屏幕，我们会写：选择三角形，点 remove。我们确实写了那段代码。我们自己调用一个函数来处理屏幕内容的增量。所以你可以想象程序是多么容易出错，因为，你知道，一个开发者在处理数百万件不同的事情。但这也是从命令式编程向声明式编程的转变，并且更多地涉及函数式编程的技术。是的，这完全说得通。就像在 Excel 中，对吧？Excel，你设置……
yeah it's kind of like uh there's something similar with with with the graphics world the computer game world like for example with open gl if you just use pure open gl you have to say you know draw the triangle wait a 60th of a second draw the triangle draw the triangle draw the triangle triangle move next time draw the triangle. But if you do something like Unity, you just say, I have a triangle and it's at x equals 3. And then you could wait a day or an hour or a minute, whatever. And then say, okay, now my triangle is at x equals 6. And Unity is responsible for just saying, draw the triangle. You're just saying how the world looks.
……这些方程。然后随着数据变化，你不必回去重新计算任何东西。它只是，它是响应式的。所以 React.js 在这方面也是响应式的。是的。而且，你知道，关于 React 是否是形式定义技术中真正的响应式系统，有很多争论。但现实是，你所说的是绝对正确的。今天使用 React 的开发者更关心操作数据，而不是描述“对于该数据的不同版本，我的屏幕应该看起来像这样”。然后他们不关心当数据变化时如何调整屏幕。
And you let Unity, the game engine, engine handle drawing it and so react is kind of that for the web exactly and the web we were working on the web exactly like you were describing with like almost like accessing the graphics card we were working on such a low level that we were concerned with things that could be basically automated i remember when ria was getting really popular a lot of people were comparing it to automatic garbage collection and going from manipulating memory manually to letting an engine do so automatically. And the metaphor is really good because the best example is in modern, very complicated software programs, you're not just dealing with like moving the triangle from A to B, you're dealing with the user saying, well, now forget about it. I don't want to try or want to
就像你说的 Excel 一样，当你改变一个数据点时，你不会去更新所有依赖于该数据点的数据点，对吧？你没有做任何手动计算。这实际上是 Excel 的真正力量。所以 React 正在把这个……
go elsewhere. And you have to ditch the triangle and you need to like get rid of it entirely from the screen. And if you think about the old world and how we used to program, we would use what we would call CSS selectors. And we say, hey, okay, the user wants to go somewhere else. So first let's clean up the screen and we'd be like, select the triangle dot remove. And we literally write that code. We invoke a function to handle this deltas of the screen's contents ourselves. So you can imagine how buggy programs were because, you know, a developer that is working on like millions of different things sometimes but it was also this transition away from imperative programming to declarative programming and just involving techniques from functional programming a lot more. Yeah, it totally makes sense. Like in Excel, right? Excel, you set up
……带到开发者面前，这真的非常非常迷人。是的，完全说得通。嘿，伙计们，我们要休息一下，谈谈加州大学欧文分校的继续教育学院。这是一个非常酷的项目。他们有各种各样的……
sort of these equations. And then as your data changes, you don't have to go back and recompute anything. It's just kind of, it's reactive. And so React.js is also reactive in that way. Yeah. And, you know, a lot of, there's been lots of debate about whether React is a truly reactive system in the, you know, formal definition of the technique. But the reality is that what you're saying is absolutely right. Like the developer that works with React today is more concerned with manipulating data than describing, okay, my screen should look like this for different versions of that data. And then they're not concerned with adapting the screen when the data changes.
……你可以获得的证书。他们有 Python、数据科学、机器学习等课程。这些是……你可以获得的证书。他们有 Python、数据科学、机器学习等课程。这些是，你知道，如果你不一定获得了机器学习学位，或者你没有作为机器学习工程师工作过很多年，这是一种获得大量知识、大量专业技能的方法。而且，我知道 Patrick 和我都参加过很多在线课程。所以这是一种提升你在特定领域知识和技能的非常好的方法。是的，我的意思是，我刚开始工作时参加了大量的在线课程。而且，对我来说，成为班级的一员，我的意思是，它总是……
Much like you're saying with Excel, when you change a data point, you're not going and updating all of the data points that depend on that data point, right? You're not doing any of the manual calculations. That is, in fact, the true power of Excel. So React is kind of bringing this
……很有趣。但是课程，自定进度的东西，有时效果很好。但有时有一个“我们每周要做什么”的进度，按照他们的课程大纲进行，这非常类似于正常的大学课程。事实上，感觉它几乎完全一样，这是一种舒适的事情，一种很好的学习方式。向那些以教学为业的教授学习，他们教导、帮助他人学习，并且能够访问它，完成作业。它确实帮助我从本科毕业的地方，过渡到……引导进入更具体、更高级的事物，那些更贴近……
in front of developers, which is really, really fascinating. Yeah, totally makes sense. Hey guys, we're going to take a little break to talk about University of California, Irvine's Division of Continuing Education. So this is a pretty cool program. They have a variety of different
……我当时工作的领域。我，你知道，我强烈推荐人们参加大学的继续教育课程。是的，是的。是的，我认为通过大学获得这些课程实际上是非常非常棒的。我的意思是，大学开始涉足这个领域真是太棒了，而且，你知道，你知道会有高质量的讲座和教授。任何主要大学背后都有一个非常强大的品牌。而加州大学欧文分校是计算机科学领域顶尖的大学之一。
kind of certificates that you could acquire. They have things like Python, they have data science, they have machine learning. And these are things where, you know, kind of certificates that you could acquire. They have things like Python, they have data science, they have machine learning. And these are things where, you know, if you didn't necessarily get, let's say a degree in machine learning, or you haven't worked in a, in a, in a, as a machine learning engineer for a bunch of years, um, this is a way to sort of get a lot of that knowledge, a lot of that expertise. And, you know, I know Patrick and I, we've both done a bunch of courses online. And so it's a really good way to sort of boost, you know, your knowledge and your skills in a particular area. Yeah. I mean, I did tons of online classes when I first started working. And, you know, for me, being part of a class, I mean, it's always
所以他们大约从 1962 年左右就开始了，我想。他们已经存在很长时间了。他们一直在做，你知道，他们教学已经很长时间了。他们在线教学也已经很长时间了。所以这是一个去获得这种教育的好地方。是的。如果你感兴趣，我想他们春季的一些后期课程还在招生，但夏季的课程即将到来。正如你在这整期节目中所谈到的，我的意思是，我认为每个人这些天在家都有额外的时间。哦，天哪。如果你感兴趣，可以在 ce.uci.edu/programmingthrowdown 查看。当然，我们会把链接放在节目说明中。
interesting. But the curriculum, the self-paced stuff, it works great sometimes. But sometimes having a here's what we're doing each week, marching through their curriculum and going through it, it's very similar to how, you know, just a normal university class works. In fact, you know, feeling like it's almost exactly the same is just a comfortable thing, a good way to learn. And learning from professors who, you know, that's their thing. They teach, they help others to learn and having access to it, doing the assignments. It really helped me go from, you know, where my undergraduate left off to, you know, to just kind of bootstrapping into more specifics, higher level things, things that were more pertinent
但再说一次，是 ce.uci.edu/programmingthrowdown。是的，如果你注册并参加了任何课程，我们很乐意得到反馈。请写信告诉我们你的想法。我们可以转达给他们。但对我们来说，了解你们这些听众的想法也非常好。所以，好的，回到节目。关于 React 的一点，可能对大家来说有点难的是……你知道，有 JSX，就像……
to my job at the time. I, you know, I, I highly recommend people taking classes, continuing education from a, from a college. Yep. Yep. Yeah. I think getting it through a university is, is actually a really, really stellar. I mean, it's really awesome that universities are starting to get into this and, um, you know, you know that there's going to be sort of quality lectures and professors. There's a very strong brand behind any sort of major university. And UC Irvine is one of the top universities for CS.
……你混合 HTML 和 JavaScript 的方式，我知道这让很多人感到困惑。但如今，你知道，有了非常好的 IDE 支持，这让整个过程变得容易多了。我的意思是，你得到了正确的语法高亮，如果做错了什么，IDE 会立刻告诉你。所以我认为对于新手来说，将 React.js 与好的 IDE 和好的开发系统结合起来非常重要。是的，这也是我们发明 Next.js 的原因，对吧？所以 React 最初是一种机制，旨在能够捕捉 Facebook 代码库中不断增长的新兴且无情的复杂性。你知道，有一类 bug，一类 bug 不断地……
So they've been around since about 1962, I think. And they've been around a long time. They've been doing, you know, they've been teaching a long time. They've been teaching online a long time. And so it's a good place to go and get this kind of education. Yeah. If you're interested, I think they're still doing enrollment for some late classes for spring, but summer's upcoming. And as you've been talking about this whole episode, I mean, I think everyone has extra time at home these days. Oh, my gosh. If you're interested, you can check it out at ce.uci.edu slash programming throwdown. And we'll put the link in the show notes, of course.
我想他们从1962年左右就开始存在了。他们已经存在很长时间了。你知道，他们一直在教学，而且在线教学也已经很久了。所以这是一个获取此类教育的好地方。是的。如果你感兴趣，我想他们春季的一些后期课程还在招生，但夏季课程也快开始了。正如你在这一整集中所谈到的，我的意思是，我认为大家最近在家都有额外的时间。天哪。如果你感兴趣，可以访问 ce.uci.edu/programmingthrowdown 查看。当然，我们会在节目说明中附上链接。
But once again, that's ce.uci.edu slash programming throwdown. Yeah, and if you do sign up and take any courses, we'd love to get feedback. Please write us in. Tell us what you think of it. We could pass it on to them. But also for us, it's really good to know what you thought about that, folks out there who are listening. So, all right, back to the show the thing about react that um might be a little tough for folks is um is you know there's the the um uh jsx like there's
再说一次，网址是 ce.uci.edu/programmingthrowdown。是的，如果你注册并参加了任何课程，我们很乐意收到反馈。请写信告诉我们你的想法。我们可以将其转达给他们。这对我们来说也非常重要，可以了解听众朋友们的想法。好了，回到节目。关于 React，对大家来说可能有点困难的地方是，你知道，有 JSX，就像有
like a the way you sort of mix the html and the javascript i know that throws a lot of folks off um but nowadays you know with the uh really nice ide support, that makes that whole process a lot easier. I mean, you get the right syntax highlighting, and the IDE will tell you right away if you do something wrong. And so I think combining React.js, for new folks, combining React.js with a good IDE and a good development system is really important. Yeah, and this is kind of why we invented NGIS too, right? So React started as a mechanism for kind of being able to capture the emerging and kind of relentless complexity that was growing within Facebook's code base. You know, there were classes of bugs, categories of bugs that kept
就像你混合 HTML 和 JavaScript 的方式，我知道这让很多人感到困惑。但如今，有了非常好的 IDE 支持，整个过程变得容易多了。我的意思是，你可以获得正确的语法高亮显示，如果做错了什么，IDE 会立即告诉你。所以我认为对于新手来说，将 React.js 与好的 IDE 和良好的开发系统结合起来非常重要。是的，这也是我们发明 NGIS 的原因，对吧？所以 React 最初是一种机制，旨在捕捉 Facebook 代码库中不断增长且难以控制的复杂性。你知道，有些类别的错误一直在出现
happening that were frustrating the developers who were saying, you know, like, I think one of the interesting things that I've learned about software engineering is that the appreciation for categories of problems rather than problems as independent, unique things really makes a world of difference, right? Like, you don't want to spend your time fixing, like things, novel little things that come up, you try to say, okay, this belongs in this category of problem. Let's try to find ways that we can fix the category, rather than patch each issue as it happens. Yeah. Fixing the root cause, right? And there were categories of issues that were happening within Facebook that are very much related to what I was sharing earlier.
当时发生的事情让开发人员感到非常沮丧，他们说，你知道，我认为我在软件工程中学到的有趣的事情之一是，对问题类别的理解，而不是将问题视为独立的、独特的事物，这真的会带来巨大的不同，对吧？比如，你不想把时间花在修复那些新出现的、琐碎的小问题上，你会尝试说，好吧，这属于这一类问题。让我们试着找到修复这一类问题的方法，而不是在每个问题出现时都打补丁。是的，修复根本原因，对吧？Facebook 内部确实存在一些问题类别，这与我之前分享的内容非常相关。
Like, hey, I'll give you an example also with the clock. Cleaning up stuff when something that was on the screen is not there anymore was always a challenge for web developers. For example, the clock has to repaint every second so that we can make the time change, but we can make, I don't know, the column flicker so that we have a nice animation for our clock.
比如，我再给你举个时钟的例子。当屏幕上的东西不再需要时，清理这些东西对 Web 开发人员来说一直是个挑战。例如，时钟必须每秒重绘一次，这样我们才能让时间发生变化，但我们也可以让，我不知道，让列闪烁，这样我们的时钟就会有一个漂亮的动画。
What happens when you navigate away or you just go to another portion of the system where that clock is not there anymore? So a category of problem that would happen a lot was like the developer would correctly remove the clock from the screen because that's a clock lingering there that you didn't want but what they would forget is it cleared the timer that was trying to every second um clean up the update the clock and do an animation whatever so um the interesting thing about this is that it would be completely silent that timer would be running in the background because of an implementation detail in jQuery which is a library that people were using a lot of the time, which when you would select an element that was no longer on the screen,
当你导航离开，或者进入系统的另一个部分，而那个时钟不再存在时，会发生什么？所以一个经常发生的问题类别是，开发人员会正确地从屏幕上移除时钟，因为那是你不需要的残留时钟，但他们会忘记清除那个试图每秒钟清理、更新时钟并进行动画处理的计时器，等等。所以，关于这一点有趣的是，它是完全静默的，那个计时器会在后台运行，这是因为 jQuery 中的一个实现细节，这是一个人们经常使用的库，当你选择一个不再在屏幕上的元素时，
it would just swallow the error. So basically, if no HTML element matched your selector, in this case, the clock was not there, and you were trying to do something, like update it or whatever, jQuery would just say like oh it's all okay and then you would have all this load accumulating in the background that is completely invisible to both developer and user so this is really bad you know especially at the
它只会吞掉错误。所以基本上，如果没有 HTML 元素匹配你的选择器，在这种情况下，时钟不在那里，而你试图做一些事情，比如更新它之类的，jQuery 就会说，哦，没关系，然后你就会在后台积累所有这些完全对开发人员和用户不可见的负载，所以这真的很糟糕，你知道，特别是在
scale of facebook where like people spend a lot of time on on uh like navigating their news feed or there's lots of things that are constantly updating, right? Like you've seen how likes update in real time. You've seen how comments update in real time. Now they incorporated that your friend is typing in a newsfeed post. There's video, there's polls
Facebook 这种规模下，人们花大量时间在浏览他们的动态消息上，或者有很多东西在不断更新，对吧？就像你看到点赞是如何实时更新的。你看到评论是如何实时更新的。现在他们加入了你的朋友正在动态消息中输入内容的功能。有视频，有投票，
and everything auto updates. So imagine managing all that complexity manually, all those timers, all those subscriptions to real-time updates from the server. It was resembling a very complex video game, really, with lots of characters animating on the screen and things like that. So when they needed to solve these categories of problems,
而且一切都会自动更新。所以想象一下手动管理所有这些复杂性，所有这些计时器，所有这些来自服务器的实时更新订阅。这真的就像一个非常复杂的电子游戏，屏幕上有许多角色在做动画等等。所以当他们需要解决这些类别的问题时，
they created React. But what we noticed, and this goes to your point about usability and IDEs and making things easy, is that people needed a very easy way of using React for everything. So Facebook at the time was concerned with incrementally adopting their own invention and solving, you know, the most pressing problems. Like, if I remember correctly, I've heard in their team that, you know, the notification center was something that they wanted to fix immediately with React. The chat windows that kind of hover over your screen is something they wanted to fix with React. Like more of the challenging pieces of the UI that, again, deal with lots of data updates. So as of this morning, I was reading on Twitter, like people were annoyed that for whatever
他们创造了 React。但我们注意到，这回到了你关于可用性和 IDE 以及让事情变得简单的问题，人们需要一种非常简单的方法来使用 React 处理所有事情。所以 Facebook 当时关心的是逐步采用他们自己的发明并解决最紧迫的问题。比如，如果我没记错的话，我从他们的团队听说，你知道，通知中心是他们想用 React 立即修复的东西。那种悬浮在屏幕上的聊天窗口是他们想用 React 修复的东西。更多的是那些具有挑战性的 UI 部分，它们同样需要处理大量的数据更新。所以今天早上，我在 Twitter 上看到，人们很恼火，因为无论
reason, a bug on the system, like the notification count is not updating correctly. So those are kind of the pressing things that Facebook was solving with React at the time. But what we noticed is, hey, this model that Facebook is using for very specific components, what if we could use that to build the entirety of a website or the entirety of a web application? What if React is your starting point and React really kind of becomes your language so that you don't have to relearn all these painful practices of HTML and jQuery and imperative programming. What if you could just start your project and everything is already configured for you? React is configured. All the production optimizations are figured out for you.
什么原因，系统出了个 bug，比如通知计数没有正确更新。所以这些就是 Facebook 当时用 React 解决的紧迫问题。但我们注意到，嘿，Facebook 用于特定组件的这种模式，如果我们能用它来构建整个网站或整个 Web 应用程序会怎样？如果 React 是你的起点，并且 React 真正成为了你的语言，这样你就不必重新学习所有这些痛苦的 HTML、jQuery 和命令式编程实践。如果你能直接开始你的项目，而且一切都已经为你配置好了会怎样？React 配置好了。所有的生产优化都为你考虑好了。
The compilation pipeline is figured out for you. And all you say is, hey, I want to start a new Next.js project. And this is kind of how Next.js was born. In fact, the need that I had when, like, React was already open source and it was already getting a lot of traction, but I needed to build one page with one form for a company to receive emails. And I was like, you know, it's very hard to assemble all the pieces. React is awesome, but starting from scratch is so difficult that it felt like you were
编译流水线也为你考虑好了。你只需要说，嘿，我想开始一个新的 Next.js 项目。这就是 Next.js 的诞生方式。事实上，当 React 已经开源并且已经获得了很多关注时，我确实有这个需求，但我需要为一个公司构建一个带有一个表单的页面来接收电子邮件。我当时想，你知道，组装所有这些部分非常困难。React 很棒，但从零开始太难了，感觉就像你在
configuring a compiler and writing a file. Yeah, just to give some insight into this, so yeah yeah the react is you know you don't like in react you can have a calendar tag right but html as we talked about doesn't that tag doesn't exist so react has to do is it has to turn all of these tags that you invented um you know into the into their you know basic components and it does that by by basically compiling a lot of these files down into essentially another language or some generated code that's not human readable. And that process is pretty expensive.
配置编译器和编写文件。是的，为了深入了解这一点，所以是的，React 是，你知道，你不喜欢在 React 中你可以有一个日历标签，对吧？但正如我们所讨论的，HTML 中不存在那个标签，所以 React 必须做的是，它必须把你发明的所有这些标签，你知道，变成它们的基本组件，它通过基本上将许多这些文件编译成本质上是另一种语言或一些非人类可读的生成代码来做到这一点。这个过程非常昂贵。
It takes time to do all of that. There's challenges around hot reloading. Ideally, you want to change a component and see the result right away. Or at least you don't want to have to compile every file. There's just so much complexity there. And there's Create React App, which is a wrapper project
做所有这些都需要时间。热重载周围存在挑战。理想情况下，你希望更改一个组件并立即看到结果。或者至少你不希望必须编译每个文件。那里有太多的复杂性。而且有 Create React App，这是一个包装项目，
that gives you kind of an initial react app with a lot of the bells and whistles but um but even that then is now complicated and so you have to do with like proxies and and a whole bunch of other things there and so yeah and what you're saying it really goes to the heart of the problem right like the reality is that react is not a native thing of the web again going back to like how the web was created and like how it was evolved and the standard systems that are around it react is like a foreign body in all this right like it was something that a company invented it was made open source and it interoperates with the primitives of the system. The primitives of the system are HTML, JS, and CSS.
它为你提供了一个初始的 React 应用程序，带有许多花哨的功能，但是，即使是这样，现在也变得复杂了，所以你必须处理代理和一大堆其他事情，所以是的，你所说的确实触及了问题的核心，对吧？现实情况是， React 不是 Web 的原生事物，再次回到 Web 是如何创建的，它是如何演变的，以及它周围的标准系统，React 就像这一切中的一个外来体，对吧？它是一家公司发明的，它是开源的，它与系统的原语进行互操作。系统的原语是 HTML、JS 和 CSS。
So something that MixJS does, for example, is really interesting. I was giving the example of the blog. So if you're designing your blog, you're thinking about it in terms of components. And we use this JSX language that allows you to refer to components as if they were HTML- looking tags inside your code. So when you're designing your blog, you define a function called blog and you say return and you include the header tag and you include the blog post tag, which are all these components, and they include the heading component and the text component and then the footer component
所以 MixJS 所做的一件事，例如，非常有趣。我刚才举了博客的例子。所以如果你在设计你的博客，你是在组件的层面思考它。我们使用这种 JSX 语言，它允许你在代码中引用组件，就像它们是看起来像 HTML 的标签一样。所以当你设计你的博客时，你定义一个名为 blog 的函数，你说 return，然后你包含 header 标签，你包含 blog post 标签，这些都是组件，它们包含 heading 组件和 text 组件，然后是 footer 组件，
and then the contact form component. And you return that. And it's really nice because if you have, if you think in terms of math, you're writing these functions that have a discrete input and a discrete output. It's a beautiful thing. So like you're basically just returning components
然后是 contact form 组件。然后你返回它。这真的很好，因为如果你有，如果你用数学的角度思考，你正在编写这些具有离散输入和离散输出的函数。这是一件美妙的事情。所以你基本上只是从函数体中返回组件。
from a function body. But what happens is, again, the web speaks a different language. It doesn't speak components. It doesn't speak JSX. It doesn't even speak the new versions of these languages that people want to use. So that's where the compilation step comes in. So an interesting thing that Next.js does is that for the first impression of your website, we compile it down to HTML and CSS. So that is super, super fast. In fact, no JavaScript has to get loaded for your visitors to get, again, primitives of the web, HTML and CSS that you didn't write by hand because you
但发生的事情是，同样，Web 说的是一种不同的语言。它不说组件。它不说 JSX。它甚至不说人们想要使用的这些语言的新版本。这就是编译步骤发挥作用的地方。所以 Next.js 所做的一件有趣的事情是，对于你网站的第一印象，我们将其编译为 HTML 和 CSS。所以这非常非常快。事实上，你的访问者不需要加载任何 JavaScript 就能获得 Web 的原语，即 HTML 和 CSS，这些不是你手写的，因为你
were speaking the language of components and you were having a very nice and easy time creating your system but again we have to interoperate operate with the web that has you know billions of devices all the different versions and browsers and so on so that's where next.js is kind of like hiding all this complexity from you and it's quite you know it's quite interesting what we call this developer experience right like this is kind of the term that emerged we used to speak only of user experience ux and then at one point this word started getting traction called dx right developer experience because again like doing all this juggling of what the developer wants experience to be but then on the other side, we have this kind of,
在使用组件的语言，并且你在创建系统时非常轻松愉快，但同样，我们必须与拥有数十亿设备、所有不同版本和浏览器等的 Web 进行互操作，所以这就是 Next.js 在为你隐藏所有这些复杂性的地方，这非常有趣，我们称之为开发人员体验，对吧？这是一种出现的术语，我们过去只谈论用户体验 UX，然后有一次这个词开始流行起来，叫 DX，即开发人员体验，因为同样，在开发人员想要的体验和另一边之间进行所有这些权衡，我们有这种，
I'm not going to call it legacy system, but we have this very basic system that is a different version because of different web browsers. And we needed to build that glue to kind of make those two worlds compatible. Yeah, that makes sense. So can you explain to me a little bit, what's the, you know,
我不会称之为遗留系统，但我们有这种非常基础的系统，由于不同的 Web 浏览器，它是一个不同的版本。我们需要构建那种胶水来使这两个世界兼容。是的，这很有道理。所以你能给我解释一下，什么是，你知道，
what does Next.js build on top of React.js? So in both cases, you have JSX, which is not something the browser can understand. So we compile it down to, at least in React.js, we compile it down to HTML that's being generated by JavaScript functions. So you have this JSX file. It has a lot of these HTML tags that don't exist in the browser. And so the compilation step, you know, runs that, basically like runs through that file looks at those tags and then kind of recursively goes through and and and replaces them all with the with the right thing from from something the
Next.js 是在 React.js 之上构建的吗？所以在这两种情况下，你都有 JSX，这不是浏览器能理解的东西。所以我们将其编译为，至少在 React.js 中，我们将其编译为由 JavaScript 函数生成的 HTML。所以你有这个 JSX 文件。它有很多浏览器中不存在的 HTML 标签。所以编译步骤，你知道，运行它，基本上就像运行那个文件，查看那些标签，然后递归地遍历并用浏览器能理解的东西替换它们，
browser can understand and so what is next.js build on top of that yeah so one of the biggest things that next.js became very very popular for for that, for example, Create React App doesn't do. And this is not because Create React App existed and we're like, oh, we're going to fix it. But they both kind of came out at the same time. It's pre-rendering. So this is one of the pieces of Next.js where most of the investment went into. And it's why it's been chosen for many, many large websites and web properties that receive lots of traffic. So pre-rendering means, as you mentioned, there is all this JavaScript that has components, that has JSX and so on.
浏览器能理解的东西，那么 Next.js 是在它之上构建的吗？是的，Next.js 变得非常非常受欢迎的最大原因之一，例如，Create React App 没有做到这一点。这不是因为 Create React App 存在，我们想，哦，我们要修复它。但它们几乎是同时出现的。它是预渲染。所以这是 Next.js 的一部分，大部分投资都投入到了这里。这就是为什么它被许多大型网站和拥有大量流量的 Web 资产所选择的原因。所以预渲染意味着，正如你提到的，有所有这些包含组件、JSX 等的 JavaScript。
But we already know with the data already in there uh instead of an empty page with a lot of java strip that then has to make an hdp call to the to an api or or whatever again like that's why i mentioned this single principle of the web right like um we we host lots of news websites for example right and when the visitor comes there's kind of two worlds here like one world is you give them an empty page like no html only like a root element and you give them a big bundle of javascript that then when it boots up on the user's machine and and if you're if you've used the web a lot you probably see this sometimes and you get an empty page, and then a long time passes, and then some content magically appears. So we wanted to prevent that,
但我们已经知道数据已经在那里了，而不是一个带有大量 JavaScript 的空页面，然后必须向 API 或其他什么东西发起 HTTP 调用，同样，这就是为什么我提到 Web 的这个单一原则，对吧？我们托管了许多新闻网站，对吧？当访问者来的时候，这里有两种世界，一个世界是你给他们一个空页面，没有 HTML，只有根元素，你给他们一大捆 JavaScript，然后当它在用户的机器上启动时，如果你经常使用 Web，你可能有时会看到这种情况，你得到一个空页面，然后过了很长时间，然后一些内容神奇地出现了。所以我们想防止这种情况，
because there's large categories of pages on the internet that, you know, they don't need that extra hop. So Next.js became very, very popular because of this pre-rendering technology. And so that's kind of one you were asking at the compilation yeah that makes sense technology is underneath the other is that again uh we don't want to make the web dumb we want to make it very powerful this is even you know what react is really good at so what we do is we can take the pre-rendered markup and then we hydrate it on the client side. And then you can
因为互联网上有很大一部分页面，你知道，它们不需要额外的跳转。所以 Next.js 因为这种预渲染技术变得非常非常受欢迎。所以这就是你问的编译技术，是的，这很有道理，技术在下面，另一个是，同样，我们不想让 Web 变得愚蠢，我们想让它变得非常强大，这甚至是你所知道的 React 真正擅长的地方，所以我们所做的是，我们可以获取预渲染的标记，然后在客户端对其进行水合。然后你可以
kind of bring in endless interactivity to the website. That's why, you know, like kind of something that I kind of became a hill that I've chosen to die on for many years now is that I don't really see a distinction between a website and a web app. It really is just a matter of the developer deciding how much of the content is pre-rendered or not. You might find that some websites only pre-render very little because the content is so naturally dynamic, right? So like if you're building a multiplayer chess website, well, when you first load it, you know, there might not be that much to pre-render because again, like there's a lot of animation and interaction and the data, maybe it's stored on the, even the
引入无尽的交互性到网站。这就是为什么，你知道，这就像我多年来一直坚持的观点，我不认为网站和 Web 应用程序之间有什么区别。这真的只是开发人员决定多少内容是预渲染的问题。你可能会发现一些网站只预渲染很少的内容，因为内容本质上是动态的，对吧？所以如果你正在构建一个多人国际象棋网站，好吧，当你第一次加载它时，你知道，可能没有那么多东西可以预渲染，因为同样，有很多动画和交互，数据，也许它存储在，甚至在
local device rather than on the cloud. And there's all these needs for a very dynamic client side rendering and hydration. But if you're building a news website and something recently that happened is that, you know, we noticed that when governments were kind of, you know, rushing to get stuff out about coronavirus, they would put it on systems that would immediately collapse in their load, that would be slow, or they were taking too long to get the information out. And this is why for us, pre-rendering has been such an important feature because if you're going to tell somebody, you know, what the three-phase plan is for, you know, releasing the lockdown in the US, you're better off putting out a pre-rendered page that is primarily HTML and CSS that scales tremendously well with huge spikes of traffic. And it kind of becomes your, you know, using the web as a printing press,
本地设备而不是云端。并且对非常动态的客户端渲染和水合有所有这些需求。但如果你正在构建一个新闻网站，最近发生的一件事是，你知道，我们注意到当政府在匆忙发布关于冠状病毒的信息时，他们会把它们放在负载下会立即崩溃的系统上，这些系统会很慢，或者他们发布信息的时间太长了。这就是为什么对我们来说，预渲染一直是一个如此重要的功能，因为如果你要告诉某人，你知道，美国解除封锁的三阶段计划是什么，你最好发布一个预渲染的页面，它主要是 HTML 和 CSS，可以随着巨大的流量峰值而极好地扩展。它有点像你的，你知道，把 Web 当作印刷机，
I call it, right? Like you pre-rendered a page and that pre-rendered page becomes infinitely scalable. It's like a magical pen that you could distribute across the world. But the magic- So if I could sort of just recap for folks the audience so the idea is you know originally you had html and you had javascript
我称之为，对吧？你预渲染了一个页面，那个预渲染的页面变得无限可扩展。它就像一支可以分发到世界各地的魔法笔。但魔法——所以如果我可以为观众总结一下，这个想法是，你知道，最初你有 HTML 和 JavaScript，
and they were in separate files so someone would go and download the html file it would have and as we talked about earlier the image images were in separate files so you'd get the html file that would have you know none of the images and no logic, but it would have a lot of structure, and it would have all the text, and it would have the structure, the layout of the page. You would download the JavaScript then next, and it would have logic that could then go to a server and pull some extra information or not.
它们在单独的文件中，所以有人会去下载 HTML 文件，它会有，正如我们之前讨论的，图像在单独的文件中，所以你会得到 HTML 文件，它会有，你知道，没有图像，没有逻辑，但它会有很多结构，它会有所有的文本，它会有结构，页面的布局。你接下来会下载 JavaScript，它会有逻辑，然后可以去服务器拉取一些额外的信息或不拉取。
You don't even need a JavaScript to have a website. And it would pull all the images, right? So then when you switch to React, what you end up with for most people is the HTML page is effectively empty. And all of the React components end up turning into JavaScript functions. So you download this empty HTML file, you download this enormous JavaScript file, and then you kind of call go on this JavaScript file, which then recurses, creates a bunch of functions or launches a bunch of functions all of those create this massive string of html and then that ends up replacing the empty html um and uh and that's how you can have things like a calendar tag which aren't which don't exist right and so what you're saying here glia is that is that with next js
你甚至不需要 JavaScript 就能拥有一个网站。它会拉取所有的图像，对吧？所以当你切换到 React 时，对于大多数人来说，你最终得到的是 HTML 页面实际上是空的。所有的 React 组件最终都变成了 JavaScript 函数。所以你下载这个空的 HTML 文件，你下载这个巨大的 JavaScript 文件，然后你有点像在 JavaScript 文件上调用 go，它然后递归，创建一堆函数或启动一堆函数，所有这些都创建了这个巨大的 HTML 字符串，然后它最终替换了空的 HTML，这就是你如何拥有像日历标签这样不存在的东西，对吧？所以你在这里所说的是，Glia，是说使用 Next.js
oh yeah just to finish the React thing, and then because these websites are sort of living, breathing things, you also have an update function. So every component has your sort of render function, and then you have the ability to sort of call that again. So it's kind of on you to say, hey, go fetch some data from the network, and then call render again on this component. Yeah, I'll even say that the calling the render, this is what's fascinating.
哦，是的，只是为了完成 React 的事情，然后因为这些网站是某种活生生的、会呼吸的东西，你也有一个更新函数。所以每个组件都有你的那种渲染函数，然后你有能力再次调用它。所以这有点取决于你说，嘿，去从网络获取一些数据，然后在这个组件上再次调用渲染。是的，我甚至会说调用渲染，这才是最迷人的地方。
The calling the render for all the parts of the screen that could have possibly changed is done by React, right? So like going back to your great Excel metaphor, your job as a developer is just mostly to alter the data. As you said, with networking API calls, even sometimes like reading or writing from the local device. But then React just like says, oh, I'm going to repaint. I know what parts of the screen need to get repainted. I'm going to repaint them, right?
屏幕上所有可能发生变化的部分的渲染调用都是由 React 完成的，对吧？所以回到你那个很棒的 Excel 比喻，作为开发人员，你的工作主要只是更改数据。正如你所说，通过网络 API 调用，甚至有时像从本地设备读取或写入。但然后 React 只是说，哦，我要重绘。我知道屏幕的哪些部分需要重绘。我要重绘它们，对吧？
So there's very little work for you to do in terms of re-rendering things, which is a huge time saver yeah yeah but you still have to you're still responsible for for basically using some kind of you could use a observable type thing but but you're responsible for going out you know uh if you're if you're let's say uh if you're doing the chess example you're responsible for going to the server saying hey has the other person played yet the server comes back and says yes they have and then you have to update that um you know somewhere whether you sort of yeah however you do that is up to you but you have to go and update that um yeah and so basically so when we when we uh talk about react especially for those that are going to go deeper into it
所以你在重新渲染方面几乎没有什么工作要做，这节省了大量时间，是的，是的，但你仍然必须，你仍然负责基本上使用某种，你可以使用可观察类型的东西，但你负责出去，你知道，如果你正在做国际象棋的例子，你负责去服务器说，嘿，另一个人玩了吗？服务器回来并说是的，他们玩了，然后你必须更新那个，你知道，在某个地方，无论你如何做，这取决于你，但你必须去更新那个，是的，所以基本上，当我们谈论 React 时，特别是对于那些将要深入研究它的人，
we say a component has a state and it has a render function. And the render function returns HTML as a function of that state. So it's almost like a bijective function of, hey, here is state. It has the properties of the board, where all the pieces, and then we return a bunch of components
我们说一个组件有一个状态和一个渲染函数。渲染函数返回 HTML 作为该状态的函数。所以它几乎就像一个双射函数，嘿，这是状态。它具有棋盘的属性，所有棋子在哪里，然后我们返回一堆组件，
for like the chess pieces and so on, and React does all the heavy lifting. Yeah, and so, you know, for some of these components, the state might change very often, right? But for some of them, you know, maybe the state, you know, going to your calendar example, maybe the state just holds the day you wanted to start the calendar on. And so, for that reason, the that reason, the state isn't changing all the time. It might change if someone picks a day, but let's put that aside for now. It's not changing every minute or anything.
比如棋子等等，React 完成了所有的繁重工作。是的，所以，你知道，对于其中一些组件，状态可能会经常改变，对吧？但对于其中一些，你知道，也许状态，你知道，回到你的日历例子，也许状态只是保存了你想在日历上开始的那一天。所以，由于那个原因，状态并不是一直都在改变。如果有人选择了一天，它可能会改变，但让我们暂时把那个放在一边。它不是每分钟都在改变什么的。
And so actually the majority of your components probably change very little or none at all. And so what Next.js does is it says, let's look at the initial state of all these components. Let's call that big function that generates that huge bunch of HTML, and let's send that instead of the empty HTML. And then if there are changes, you know, we'll handle them. But at least that very first thing, which is really expensive, we could do that on our side so that each browser doesn't
所以实际上你的大多数组件可能变化很小或根本没有变化。所以 Next.js 所做的是它说，让我们看看所有这些组件的初始状态。让我们调用那个生成那一大堆 HTML 的大函数，让我们发送那个，而不是空的 HTML。然后如果有变化，你知道，我们会处理它们。但至少那第一件事，是非常昂贵的，我们可以在我们这边做，这样每个浏览器就不必
have to do it yeah yeah that that's exactly how it works and so to give you context on this transition we went from the web just being html that was like non-interactive at all and it was all coming in one hop and as you know this kind of rich JS applications with components were kind of growing and pricing, we kind of went all, we overcorrected it the other way. And this is kind of the story of how progress is made because then we've had to bring it back to the middle with Next.js a little bit, right?
做了，是的，是的，这正是它的工作方式，所以为了给你提供关于这个转变的背景，我们从 Web 只是 HTML，完全没有交互性，而且所有东西都是一次性到来的，正如你所知，这种带有组件的丰富 JS 应用程序正在增长和定价，我们有点走过了头，我们矫枉过正了。这就是进步是如何取得的故事，因为后来我们不得不通过 Next.js 把它们带回中间一点，对吧？
Because we went from, oh, now you go to a website and you get nothing in that initial response. You just get lots of JS that your phone or your computer has to boot up the JavaScript virtual machine, you know, interpret, compile it, optimize it, parse it, and then spit back out some HTML,
因为我们从，哦，现在你去一个网站，你在初始响应中什么也得不到。你只得到大量的 JS，你的手机或电脑必须启动 JavaScript 虚拟机，你知道，解释、编译它、优化它、解析它，然后吐出一些 HTML，
which is really, we're talking about that OpenGL triangle. That is how the information will actually come to your brain eventually, right? The way that, you know, data is transformed into pixels on the screen today is that fundamental HTML or DOM, you know, data structure. So we were adding latency and we were adding, as you said, megabytes of JS that had to be downloaded before doing anything at all. So Next.js was like, okay, that cannot be the only way. That's one good way for certain things, but that cannot be the only way to build things.
这实际上，我们谈论的是那个 OpenGL 三角形。这就是信息最终如何传达到你的大脑，对吧？今天数据转化为屏幕像素的方式是那个基本的 HTML 或 DOM，你知道，数据结构。所以我们增加了延迟，正如你所说，在做任何事情之前必须下载兆字节的 JS。所以 Next.js 就像，好吧，那不可能是唯一的方法。那是某些事情的一种好方法，但那不可能是构建事物的唯一方法。
So Next.js added this idea that, hey, you have all these components and all this rich JavaScript. How about we also try to pre-render it so that the user can get content and data right away? And this actually made React just way more broadly accessible and more broadly applicable to things where you would dismiss it sometimes.
所以 Next.js 增加了这个想法，嘿，你有所有这些组件和所有这些丰富的 JavaScript。我们何不也尝试预渲染它，以便用户可以立即获得内容和数据？这实际上使 React 的可访问性更广，并且更广泛地适用于你有时会忽略的事情。
You would say, oh, no, I cannot build a landing page with that. I cannot build a coronavirus instructions page with that. I cannot build a blog. I cannot build a news website. I cannot build all kinds of systems. And going back to the hill that I die on is that I don't think any system has ever fell in one direction or the other. You could have the most dynamic system in the world, but it can assure you that there are pages that are fundamentally somewhat static and you could have pre-rendered market for. I remember the first experience that I had with this thing was like I was building a very dynamic system with React and then I had in
你会说，哦，不，我不能用那个构建登录页面。我不能用那个构建冠状病毒说明页面。我不能构建博客。我不能构建新闻网站。我不能构建各种系统。回到我坚持的观点，我不认为任何系统曾经倒向一边或另一边。你可以拥有世界上最动态的系统，但我可以向你保证，有些页面本质上是静态的，你可以为它们提供预渲染的标记。我记得我第一次有这种体验是，我正在用 React 构建一个非常动态的系统，然后我有一个
as a separate file, right? And this was all written with components because that's how I wanted to build the world. I wanted to use this Lego blocks. So I built the
作为单独的文件，对吧？这都是用组件编写的，因为这就是我想构建世界的方式。我想使用这些乐高积木。所以我构建了
Anytime the user wanted to do anything at all. And as you know, a lot of visitors of the internet don't ever even go to the terms of my application in one gigantic JS bundle, anytime they used to want to do anything at all. And as you know, a lot of visitors of the internet don't ever even go to the
每当用户想做任何事情时。正如你所知，互联网的许多访问者甚至从来没有进入我的应用程序的条款，在一个巨大的 JS 包中，每当他们想做任何事情时。正如你所知，互联网的许多访问者甚至从来没有进入
and then we also have pre-fetching. So for people that are used to visiting very dynamic JavaScript apps or single page apps, as people call them sometimes, you know that the transitions are super snappy and that really feels awesome. So you touch something and then you immediately go to it. There is no delay. There is no perception that you're going to a remote server or anything like that. So as it happens, we wanted to retain that property for our system as well. So what we came up with is this idea that, hey, there's this component called link that we give you, this component you don't have to build yourself. And when you use link to link pages
然后我们还有预取。所以对于习惯于访问非常动态的 JavaScript 应用程序或单页应用程序（人们有时这样称呼它们）的人来说，你知道转换是非常迅速的，这感觉真的很棒。所以你触摸某样东西，然后你立即进入它。没有延迟。没有你正在去远程服务器的感觉。所以碰巧，我们也想为我们的系统保留这个属性。所以我们想出的是这个想法，嘿，有一个名为 link 的组件我们给你，这个组件你不必自己构建。当你使用 link 来链接页面
together we can start pre-fetching the next page before the user has even thought about going there so what you end up with is the system that merges pre-rendering with pre-fetching so you kind of have your cake and you do too so the system feels super snappy you get data in or you get a shape or you get content in the first response and you still retain all this goodness of the web you retain hyperlinks uh you retain bookmarking you retain back and forth navigation and yet things can be infinitely complex once the pages get hydrated. So that's what I'm saying. You can build anything you want with React. You can build a chess game. You can build a blog. You can really build anything. It's quite the interesting technology to learn. That's awesome. So the
在一起时，我们可以在用户甚至还没想到要去那里之前就开始预取下一个页面。所以你最终得到的是一个将预渲染与预取合并的系统，所以你有点像既想要蛋糕又想吃掉它，所以系统感觉非常迅速，你在第一次响应中获得数据或获得形状或获得内容，并且你仍然保留了 Web 的所有这些优点，你保留了超链接，你保留了书签，你保留了前后导航，然而一旦页面被水合，事情就可以变得无限复杂。这就是我所说的。你可以用 React 构建任何你想要的东西。你可以构建国际象棋游戏。你可以构建博客。你真的可以构建任何东西。这是一种非常有趣的可以学习的技术。太棒了。所以
idea is if you have your
想法是如果你有你的
First of all, we prioritize prefetching what's visible on the screen. But secondly, we don't prioritize it so much that it's getting in the way of loading the chessboard, right? Or whatever it is that that particular page that you were developing was concerned with rendering. So we actually have spent lots and lots of engineering in this intelligent prefetching system. we're really happy with where it is today, but there is so much more still that we can do. So something we're researching currently is we can know based on the trajectory of your input device, right? Whether you're likely to, where you're likely to go next, right? And we know this from several sources. One is the motion of the pointer itself,
首先，我们优先预取屏幕上可见的内容。但其次，我们不会优先考虑它，以至于它妨碍了加载棋盘，对吧？或者你正在开发的那个特定页面所关心的渲染。所以我们实际上在智能预取系统中投入了大量的工程。我们对它今天的状态非常满意，但我们仍然可以做更多的事情。所以我们目前正在研究的一件事是，我们可以根据你的输入设备的轨迹知道，对吧？你是否可能，你接下来可能去哪里，对吧？我们从几个来源知道这一点。一个是指针本身的运动，
right? Like the pointer is pointing to a certain link. We can start prefetching that. The other one is on mobile determining the motion, right? Like the user might be blindly scrolling or they're stopping and looking at something. And in a lot of cases, what we do is we start prefetching when you first begin the tap action rather than when the tap gets released and so on. And then we can use information about your traffic as well. So there is a integration for Next.js called Guess.js that uses information from Google Analytics to know what to prefetch and to prioritize prefetching.
对吧？指针指向某个链接。我们可以开始预取它。另一个是在移动设备上确定运动，对吧？用户可能在盲目滚动，或者他们停下来看某样东西。在很多情况下，我们所做的是，当你第一次开始点击动作时，我们就开始预取，而不是在点击释放时等等。然后我们也可以使用关于你的流量的信息。所以有一个名为 Guess.js 的 Next.js 集成，它使用来自 Google Analytics 的信息来知道预取什么以及优先考虑预取。
So it's quite fascinating, right? Because the only thing that you think about as a developer and you get all these benefits, it's just linking between pages. I shall say also that that's the other kind of important primitive that Next.js added to the React universe that it was, in my opinion, sorely needed, which is the page. So in the Next.js universe, you don't have just components.
所以这非常迷人，对吧？因为作为开发人员你唯一想到的事情，你得到了所有这些好处，它只是页面之间的链接。我还应该说，这是 Next.js 添加到 React 宇宙中的另一种重要的原语，在我看来，这是非常需要的，那就是页面。所以在 Next.js 宇宙中，你不仅仅有组件。
You define what pages you're building first. And all those pages themselves are just React components as well. The top level thing is a component and then there's deeper components. But the fact that there is a page as a concept allows you to like i said retain all these very cool uh properties of the web but also powers this intelligent prefetching system yeah that's awesome yeah that makes a
你首先定义你正在构建什么页面。所有这些页面本身也只是 React 组件。顶层的东西是一个组件，然后有更深层的组件。但页面作为一个概念的事实允许你像我所说的那样保留所有这些非常酷的 Web 属性，但也为这个智能预取系统提供了动力，是的，这太棒了，是的，这非常有
ton of sense um so you were talking about um things that you know you're kind of looking forward to and things you're working on. So what is it kind of like to work at Vercel? How many folks work there? And what's that environment like? Yeah, so funny enough, before this coronavirus pandemic happened, we had just organized an online event for basically front-end developers. We called it Back-end Lestant because the mission of our company is to empower front-end developers and allow them to bring their websites online and web applications online with ease.
道理，嗯，所以你刚才谈到了，嗯，你所期待的事情和你正在做的事情。那么在 Vercel 工作是什么感觉？有多少人在那里工作？那个环境是什么样的？是的，很有趣，在这次冠状病毒大流行发生之前，我们刚刚为前端开发人员组织了一次在线活动。我们称之为 Back-end Lestant，因为我们公司的使命是赋能前端开发人员，让他们能够轻松地将他们的网站和 Web 应用程序上线。
And for companies to also have the opportunity to reinvent their front-ends because we know, we noticed a lot of companies kind of neglected investing in the front end and you know i always say you know front end is where your visitors are front end where your customers are so we started vercel as a way of you know tailoring and targeting and helping this front end experience problem. But before, even before the pandemic happened, we're already organizing online events like back in the stuff. Because what we've noticed is, you know, our product was already starting to enable people to work in ways that were very distributed, right? Like you didn't have to be in an office to build components, to deploy them and get a URL and share it with your teammates. So our product was already kind of like headed into this world of like, hey, like if you have a great structure, if you have a great way of dividing up the work in the world, it kind of makes sense that you'd be able to do that work from wherever you are.
并且也让公司有机会重塑他们的前端，因为我们知道，我们注意到许多公司有点忽视了对前端的投资，你知道，我总是说，你知道，前端是你的访问者所在的地方，前端是你的客户所在的地方，所以我们开始 Vercel 作为一种，你知道，定制、定位和帮助解决这个前端体验问题的方式。但在大流行发生之前，甚至在大流行发生之前，我们已经在组织像 Back-end Lestant 这样的在线活动。因为我们注意到，你知道，我们的产品已经开始使人们能够以非常分布式的方式工作，对吧？你不必在办公室里构建组件、部署它们并获得 URL 并与你的队友分享。所以我们的产品已经有点像朝着这个世界发展，嘿，如果你有一个伟大的结构，如果你有一个伟大的方式来划分世界上的工作，那么你能够从你所在的任何地方完成这项工作是有道理的。
Right. so as a company from the get-go we're very um remote friendly so even though the headquarters are in san francisco we always figured hey you know the purpose of this technology is to allow people to kind of be freed from the constraints of the physical world to begin with after all we are publishing to online media, right? So Verso was always a company that had this as a kind of guiding principle. That makes sense. It's one of the great ironies of Silicon Valley that the people who invented, or at least I guess the country that invented video conferencing. I think it was
对。所以作为一家公司，从一开始我们就非常，嗯，对远程友好，所以即使总部在旧金山，我们总是想，嘿，你知道，这项技术的目的是让人们从一开始就从物理世界的约束中解放出来，毕竟我们是在发布到在线媒体，对吧？所以 Vercel 一直是一家将此作为一种指导原则的公司。这很有道理。硅谷的一大讽刺是，发明了，或者至少我想是发明了视频会议的国家。我想它是
invented in New York, but it's sort of like, you know, then it's like everyone's sitting in a giant bullpen, right? It's like, couldn't even dog food that invention. Yeah, it's fascinating. I think it's part of a transition. I think it's part of an acceleration. A lot of people, you know, say, well, you know, we're about to enter a recession and things are going to get really bad. But I honestly see it as the opposite. I see it as we're about to enter the dawn of a lot of things that we're doing in ways that were quite paradoxical, I think. When it comes to work, I think it was a paradox. We were building tools for remote work, but the builders of the tools were not embracing remote work.
在纽约发明的，但它有点像，你知道，然后每个人都坐在一个巨大的牛栏里，对吧？就像，甚至不能自己使用那个发明。是的，这很迷人。我认为这是转变的一部分。我认为这是加速的一部分。很多人，你知道，说，好吧，你知道，我们即将进入衰退，事情会变得非常糟糕。但我诚实地认为恰恰相反。我认为我们即将进入我们正在以相当矛盾的方式做很多事情的黎明，我想。当谈到工作时，我认为这是一个悖论。我们正在为远程工作构建工具，但工具的构建者并没有拥抱远程工作。
And I think that goes also for publishing. This is a problem that we're really attacking face-on with Vercel. We were publishing our front-ends to one location in the world. Like you mentioned AWS earlier, like the way that people use AWS by default, and this is the default region, right? They create a server in Virginia. It's the US East location, but we're publishing globally. You're selling globally. You're speaking to global audiences. Why are you putting everything in one server, right? So Vercel gives developers this workflow where they publish your edge network, which is located in dozens of cities around the world.
我认为这也适用于出版。这是我们正在 Vercel 正面攻击的问题。我们正在将我们的前端发布到世界上的一个位置。就像你之前提到的 AWS，人们默认使用 AWS 的方式，这是默认区域，对吧？他们在弗吉尼亚州创建了一个服务器。它是美国东部位置，但我们正在全球发布。你正在全球销售。你正在与全球受众交谈。为什么要把所有东西都放在一个服务器里，对吧？所以 Vercel 为开发人员提供了这种工作流程，他们发布你的边缘网络，该网络位于世界各地的几十个城市。
So when you publish your pages, when you publish your content, there's no way to deploy just to Virginia. This is a new normal, is deploy your front end to an edge network. So in some ways, you know, like you could argue, oh, we're, you know, a little bit ahead of the curve and whatever. But I think what's going to happen is that with this new world, people are going to realize these things that were already problems that were pre-existing to our systems. And now those solutions will see an acceleration in adoption because we need them. And we needed them before this even happened.
所以当你发布你的页面，当你发布你的内容时，没有办法只部署到弗吉尼亚州。这是一种新常态，就是将你的前端部署到边缘网络。所以在某些方面，你知道，你可以争辩说，哦，我们，你知道，有点领先于曲线什么的。但我认为将会发生的是，随着这个新世界，人们会意识到这些已经是我们系统预先存在的问题。现在这些解决方案将看到采用的加速，因为我们需要它们。甚至在大流行发生之前，我们就需要它们。
Yeah, when I look at, you know, when I hear reasons as to why things can't be decentralized, it always comes down to things like we'll have to document our code more. Like we'll have to have we'll have to have contracts between the teams, you know, like software contracts between the teams. And I'm just sitting there like, okay, that sounds amazing. You know, and it's like, no, no, no, we'll need an extra, you know, let's say 10% more people, you know, to do all of these things, to have all this awesome documentation. It's like, yeah, I mean, that sounds like an amazing trade-off. And in exchange, those people can be anywhere they want. I mean, it sounds like favorite essays online that I come back to a lot is this interview to a researcher out of MIT who works on what he calls digital reality
是的，当我看到，你知道，当我听到关于为什么事情不能去中心化的理由时，总是归结为诸如我们需要更多地记录我们的代码之类的事情。比如我们需要在团队之间签订合同，你知道，就像团队之间的软件合同。我坐在那里想，好吧，这听起来很棒。你知道，就像，不，不，不，我们需要额外的人手，比如说多出10%，你知道，来做所有这些事情，来拥有所有这些很棒的文档。这就像，是的，我的意思是，这听起来是一个很棒的权衡。作为交换，这些人可以在他们想要的任何地方。我的意思是，这听起来像是我经常回看的在线最喜欢的文章，这是对一位麻省理工学院研究人员的采访，他致力于他所谓的数字现实
and in the field of his research is to try to understand what exactly is the distinction between an atom and a bit and what are the technologies that facilitate the conversion from the bit to the atom right and the most obvious one is 3d printer right like you have content that is purely software defined and then you can convert it into reality. And one of the things that he talks about, and he talks about Lego pieces as well, is that the geometry of the pieces is what enables the system to get complex. And he talks about how, you know, you've probably seen this with like, you know, how we can birth human beings that end up being larger than the human being that they were born from, right? Like, there's this incredible complexity that yields from very basic pieces,
他的研究领域是试图理解原子和比特之间到底有什么区别，以及促进从比特到原子转换的技术是什么，对吧？最明显的就是3D打印机，对吧？你拥有纯粹由软件定义的内容，然后你可以将其转换为现实。他谈论的事情之一，他也谈到了乐高积木，就是积木的几何形状使系统变得复杂。他谈到了，你知道，你可能已经看到了，比如，你知道，我们如何能孕育出最终比他们出生时的人类更大的人类，对吧？就像，从非常基本的碎片中产生了这种令人难以置信的复杂性，
as long as these pieces can fit with one another, we can build really complex, interesting things. And John Conway died recently. And his idea of Game of Life is very similar from how very simple rules very interesting complexity can emerge and i think the way that i see this play out in the software engineering world is that we sometimes have ignored the geometry of the pieces and we have built things that are just so incompatible with one another and react made this gigantic contribution saying, hey, the building block is the component. And now you can fit the pieces together really well. And now that means that we can build complexity in ways that are actually good, right? Like we don't want to build complexity to make
只要这些碎片可以相互吻合，我们就可以构建非常复杂、有趣的东西。约翰·康威最近去世了。他的“生命游戏”理念与非常简单的规则如何产生非常有趣的复杂性非常相似，我认为我在软件工程世界中看到这种情况的方式是，我们有时忽略了碎片的几何形状，我们构建的东西彼此之间非常不兼容，而React做出了这个巨大的贡献，说，嘿，构建块就是组件。现在你可以很好地将这些碎片拼在一起。这意味着我们可以以真正好的方式构建复杂性，对吧？我们不想为了让
the world worse. But now you can manage that complexity. And you started from one little component, and you can grow out of that into a very interesting machine and go into your comment about comments in software engineering you know like i think our job really is to always be defying these nice contracts so that you know we make certain classes of problems completely irrelevant or invalid uh version control has helped us go in that direction, but I think we're going to see that become even more and more rigorous over time. Today, when you push a commit to Git, in a lot of cases, it contains no validation whatsoever. This system treats everything as just dumb text. But as we evolve our systems, we start getting
世界变得更糟而构建复杂性。但现在你可以管理这种复杂性。你从一个小组件开始，你可以从中成长为一个非常有趣的机器，回到你关于软件工程中注释的评论，你知道，我认为我们的工作确实是始终定义这些好的合同，这样你知道，我们使某些类的问题变得完全无关紧要或无效。版本控制帮助我们朝着这个方向发展，但我认为随着时间的推移，我们会看到它变得越来越严格。今天，当你向Git推送提交时，在很多情况下，它根本不包含任何验证。这个系统把一切都当作愚蠢的文本来处理。但随着我们系统的发展，我们开始获得
better understanding of what should be accepted or should be rejected altogether. And honestly, I hope that, you know, us defining collectively these better interfaces will just, I think it'll make work a lot more pleasant so that we can focus on the creative sides of software engineering rather than like the bugs and all that boring stuff. Yeah. I mean, a good example of this is code style, right? I mean, people would just fight and argue about code style. And then finally, we got editor config and we got the prettier, that's right. I forgot the C++. Oh, yeah, Clang format.
对应该接受什么或应该完全拒绝什么有更好的理解。老实说，我希望，你知道，我们共同定义这些更好的接口，我认为这会让工作变得更愉快，这样我们就可以专注于软件工程的创造性方面，而不是像bug和所有那些无聊的事情。是的。我的意思是，一个很好的例子是代码风格，对吧？我的意思是，人们会为了代码风格而争吵。然后最后，我们有了editor config，我们有了prettier，没错。我忘了C++了。哦，是的，Clang format。
But basically, we got these machines and these rules that do it for us. And now, as you said, we can focus on, you know, we don't have to spend time arguing about tabs and spaces. We can focus on more important things. You mentioned something really interesting. You mentioned hot module replacement earlier. And I really think that React has also helped popularize, you know, hot module replacement. So for those that are not familiar, as you're editing your code, and you save it, you automatically see the change in real time with no interaction with no refresh button on the screen. And this
但基本上，我们有了这些机器和规则来为我们做这件事。现在，正如你所说，我们可以专注于，你知道，我们不必花时间争论制表符和空格。我们可以专注于更重要的事情。你提到了一个非常有趣的事情。你之前提到了热模块替换。我真的认为React也帮助普及了，你知道，热模块替换。所以对于那些不熟悉的人，当你编辑代码并保存它时，你会实时自动看到变化，无需交互，屏幕上没有刷新按钮。而这
has been a really interesting thing about React is that because it defined this incredible geometry lots of other trends emerged together with it so hud module replacement you could argue could have always been possible but why did it become a thing that react became known for well because the encapsulation of components and state and like the ability to cheaply repaint, like all that led to, okay, this new amazing capability is now we take it for granted because for example, Next.js automatically configures and gives you hot module replacement. But again, like you go back, you know, 30 years, 10 years, five years, or even you go and look at how you mentioned desktop applications, how people develop desktop applications. And sometimes wait you know five minutes from a change to compiling it
一直是React一个非常有趣的事情，因为由于它定义了这种令人难以置信的几何形状，许多其他趋势也随之出现，所以热模块替换，你可以说一直都是可能的，但为什么它成为了React闻名的事情呢？嗯，因为组件和状态的封装，以及廉价重绘的能力，所有这些都导致了，好吧，这个新的惊人功能现在我们认为理所当然，因为例如，Next.js自动配置并为你提供热模块替换。但同样，你回到，你知道，30年前，10年前，5年前，或者甚至你去看你提到的桌面应用程序，人们如何开发桌面应用程序。有时从更改到编译它需要等待你知道五分钟
to running it to seeing you know what the result of their change is so just imagine what that has done for creativity and just productivity and just ease of use and onboarding developers. I'm noticing this fascinating thing on Twitter. It's called hashtag 100 days of code, where people are every day, you know, doing one challenge a day. And I noticed how fast newcomers to the industry are picking up React. And it's just really motivating for me to see, you know, that we can be a part of helping that movement come alive, which is,
到运行它，到看到你知道他们更改的结果是什么，所以想象一下这对创造力、生产力和开发人员入门的易用性做了什么。我注意到Twitter上有一个迷人的东西。它叫#100DaysOfCode，人们每天都在做，你知道，每天做一个挑战。我注意到行业新人学习React的速度有多快。看到我们能够参与帮助这一运动实现，这对我来说真的很激励，这是，
you mentioned something interesting as well. It's like people switching professions, which I always see as an opportunity to also bring fresh new ideas to our field. I think that idea that you can go back and forth from, you know, an expertise that you already had to a new expertise or a new medium for publishing. It's absolutely fascinating. We've been, with Vercel, we've been
你也提到了一个有趣的事情。就像人们转换职业一样，我总是将其视为为我们的领域带来新鲜想法的机会。我认为你可以从你已经拥有的专业知识回到新的专业知识或新的出版媒介的想法。这绝对令人着迷。我们，和Vercel一起，我们一直在
sponsoring researchers of coronavirus, of immunology, of virology. And we had the really great opportunity to sponsor a team, I believe it was out of Switzerland, of very renowned researchers. And something that really stood out to me was that they were all proficient in React and Next.js, even though that's not their thing. They were using the technology to create these interactive models
赞助冠状病毒、免疫学、病毒学的研究人员。我们有非常好的机会赞助一个团队，我相信是来自瑞士的，非常著名的研究人员。让我印象深刻的是，他们都精通React和Next.js，尽管那不是他们的专业。他们正在使用这项技术来创建这些交互式模型
with drag and drop sliders. You know, I'm sure that the idea that they changed the data and then the screen reacts automatically made lots of sense to them and it was easy to grok. And then they only had one person in the team that was more of a traditionally trained software engineer, but everybody was contributing to this project. So this is kind of what we're still in the early innings of seeing this impact that React is having in the world. But I think it's going to be,
带有拖放滑块。你知道，我相信他们更改数据然后屏幕自动反应的想法对他们来说很有意义，而且很容易理解。然后他们团队中只有一个人是受过传统培训的软件工程师，但每个人都为这个项目做出了贡献。所以这就是我们仍然处于早期阶段看到的React对世界产生的影响。但我认为它将会是，
you know, cross-disciplinary. I think it's going to, you know, help novices and professionals alike. We still work with lots of customers that have, you know, spaghetti PHP and JS code, you know, all intermingled with lots of the categories of bugs that React has eliminated. But they're still code, you know, all intermingled with lots of the categories of bugs that
你知道，跨学科的。我认为它将会，你知道，帮助新手和专业人士。我们仍然与许多客户合作，他们有，你知道，意大利面条式的PHP和JS代码，你知道，所有这些都与React消除的许多类别的bug混在一起。但他们仍然是代码，你知道，所有这些都与React消除的许多类别的bug混在一起。
React has eliminated. But they're still making, you know, like lots and lots of money. And like, they have very successful businesses, but they still, you know, are looking for that opportunity to like, reinvent their front end. So it really has been a revolution kind of across all fields and all levels of expertise. Yeah, it's amazing i do think that that um that yeah we'll sort of a lot of these things will kind of democratize as as as we have been i think you know on my side i do a lot more on the machine learning and ai side and you know pie torch and tensorflow and these technologies have done the same thing where you see um there's a person who made uh people are making like art with neural networks and they're they're you know people who like
React已经消除了。但他们仍然在，你知道，赚很多很多的钱。而且，他们有非常成功的业务，但他们仍然，你知道，在寻找重塑前端的机会。所以这确实是一场跨越所有领域和所有专业水平的革命。是的，这太棒了，我确实认为，嗯，是的，随着我们一直以来的情况，很多这些事情会以某种方式民主化，我认为，你知道，在我这边，我在机器学习和人工智能方面做了更多的工作，你知道，PyTorch和TensorFlow以及这些技术也做了同样的事情，你看到，有一个人制作了，人们正在用神经网络制作艺术，他们是，你知道，喜欢
artists and and people who don't have a background in software are able to like participate it's not just kind of for wizards anymore which is i think you're going to see as you said this sort of cambrian explosion of ideas as all these people from around the world can kind of express themselves, right? Using this new tech. Yeah, absolutely. I'm really excited because it's the programming model for me that was really the game changer. I remember when I got into React, I didn't actually use React. I wrote my own React because I really wanted to understand the... Yeah, that makes sense. What's going on here? And it just blew me away that, you know, oh, like this is a new way of thinking, really. This is a new way to program, not just, you know, like a JS library.
艺术家和没有软件背景的人能够参与其中，这不再仅仅是为向导准备的了，我认为你会看到，正如你所说，这种寒武纪大爆发的想法，因为世界各地的这些人都可以以某种方式表达自己，对吧？使用这种新技术。是的，绝对。我真的很兴奋，因为对我来说，编程模型才是真正的游戏规则改变者。我记得当我进入React时，我实际上并没有使用React。我自己写了一个React，因为我真的想了解……是的，这很有道理。这里发生了什么？它让我大吃一惊，你知道，哦，这真的是一种新的思维方式。这是一种新的编程方式，不仅仅是，你知道，像一个JS库。
And so much so that, you know, SwiftUI, the new library that Apple put out for native UI programming, is very much inspired by React. And we're seeing, you know, this inspiration of React just, you know, go everywhere. And that's because of the programming model, not because, you know, like Facebook developers wrote very good code, which they did,
以至于，你知道，SwiftUI，苹果推出的用于原生UI编程的新库，在很大程度上受到了React的启发。我们看到，你知道，这种React的灵感只是，你知道，无处不在。这是因为编程模型，而不是因为，你知道，像Facebook开发人员写了非常好的代码，尽管他们确实写了，
but like it goes beyond the code. And that's really, really interesting to me. Yeah, that makes sense. So Vercel, the company, are you folks hiring? Do you have internships? Is there any statement? We are, and we're specifically also hiring for interns. We basically run permanent internship programs.
但这超越了代码。这对我来说真的非常非常有趣。是的，这很有道理。那么Vercel这家公司，你们在招聘吗？你们有实习吗？有什么声明吗？我们有，而且我们特别也在招聘实习生。我们基本上运行永久的实习计划。
We always have our application process open to anybody that wants to get deep into this front-end world. There's two classes of problems that we invest in. One is, what is the right cloud infrastructure for a modern front-end? So what, like I mentioned, an edge network, global delivery mechanisms of infrastructure, like minimizing latency, minimizing the friction between the page and the visitor. So that's one category. The other category is we work on Next.js itself. We work on our own dashboards and ways of sharing the information about the projects that you have, the pages that you've built. And so you can basically contribute to our company in those two main areas, both infrastructure and purely front-end code.
我们的申请流程始终对任何想要深入了解这个前端世界的人开放。我们投资两类问题。一是，什么是现代前端的正确云基础设施？所以，就像我提到的，边缘网络，基础设施的全球交付机制，比如最小化延迟，最小化页面和访问者之间的摩擦。所以这是一类。另一类是我们致力于Next.js本身。我们致力于我们自己的仪表板以及分享关于你拥有的项目、你构建的页面的信息的方式。所以你基本上可以在这两个主要领域为我们公司做出贡献，即基础设施和纯前端代码。
Right now, we're attacking some really interesting issues with Next.js that have to do with scaling to very, very large projects. So projects, we're talking with millions of pages or tens of millions of pages uh or tens of millions of pages um and one thing that i love about our internship program is we've seen people that came in as interns that are now our full-time you know senior software engineers and we kind of helped them throughout that entire transition so um in addition to that we're hiring for, dev role. Basically, you can go to versatile.com slash jobs and get the full list. But yeah, we'd love to stay in touch with everybody that kind of listened to us today. Also on Twitter, my handle is RouchG. And also for anybody that's interested in Next.js and learning React or starting to build something useful with React, we recommend Next.js.org.learn, which is basically a step-by-step tutorial on building something with React from scratch.
现在，我们正在解决Next.js的一些非常有趣的问题，这些问题与扩展到非常非常大的项目有关。所以项目，我们谈论的是数百万个页面或数千万个页面，或者数千万个页面，我喜欢我们实习计划的一点是，我们看到作为实习生进来的人现在是我们全职的，你知道，高级软件工程师，我们帮助他们完成了整个过渡，所以，除此之外，我们正在招聘开发角色。基本上，你可以去versatile.com/jobs获取完整列表。但是是的，我们很乐意与今天听我们节目的人保持联系。也在Twitter上，我的账号是RouchG。对于任何对Next.js感兴趣并学习React或开始用React构建有用东西的人，我们推荐Next.js.org.learn，这基本上是一个关于从零开始用React构建东西的分步教程。
Cool. So I think folks are interested step one i would say go to next.js.org learn so that uh um you know this is a not to go on too much of a tangent but um i saw something recently where someone applied to to a job and um i thought i felt like they were a pretty good software engineer but they they actually kind of knew nothing about the company or uh or or like any anything kind of you know like anything that they're sort of getting into and so you don't want to be that person so uh so check out i think that's a really good point not only because it just helps your chances in a very objective sense it's like i think it allows you and this is kind of like a byproduct of this new open source world is you can get to know the
酷。所以我认为大家感兴趣的第一步，我会说去next.js.org learn，这样，嗯，你知道，这不是为了跑题太多，但是，我最近看到有人申请了一份工作，我认为我觉得他们是一个相当不错的软件工程师，但他们实际上对公司一无所知，或者，或者，或者像任何他们正在进入的东西，所以你不想成为那样的人，所以，所以去看看，我认为这是一个很好的观点，不仅因为它在客观意义上增加了你的机会，我认为它允许你，这有点像这个新的开源世界的副产品，你可以去了解
people that you would be working with and the problems that they're working on prior to making any kind of commitment right yeah that's right yeah totally right um yeah you can see kind of uh um you know i think a really good side of people is when when you have sort of design arguments um that's actually a side of people where you get to see kind of uh the real metal right and and what that give and take is like and everything. And all of that is out there in the public. I have a bunch of open source repos. But people have told me feedback.
你将要与之共事的人以及他们在做出任何承诺之前正在处理的问题，对吧？是的，那是对的，是的，完全正确，嗯，是的，你可以看到，你知道，我认为人们非常好的一面是，当你进行某种设计争论时，那实际上是人们让你看到某种真实本质的一面，对吧？以及那种给予和索取是什么样的，等等。所有这些都在公共场合。我有一堆开源仓库。但人们给了我反馈。
They say I'm very short when I talk online. So that is something that maybe I'll work on. Maybe I won't. I don't know. But you can see uh you know what what the folks are like which is awesome and learn more about Next.js and then yeah if you're a folk uh if you're folks out there in in in college or or uh high school um you know and you you're interested in doing an internship definitely reach out um for sure nextjs.org
他们说我在网上说话很简短。所以这是我可能会努力改进的事情。也许我不会。我不知道。但你可以看到，你知道，人们是什么样的，这太棒了，了解更多关于Next.js的信息，然后是的，如果你是大学或高中的朋友，你知道，你有兴趣做实习，一定要联系，肯定，nextjs.org
slash jobs is that correct no uh next.js.org slash well. Is that correct? No, nextjs.org slash. Well, you'll find your way if you just go to nextjs.org. You can go to the Vercel website by clicking on the top. Oh, I see. Got it. Okay, cool, cool. Great. Yeah, this is really, really awesome.
slash jobs，那是对的吗？不，next.js.org slash。那是对的吗？不，nextjs.org slash。好吧，如果你去nextjs.org，你会找到你的路。你可以通过点击顶部进入Vercel网站。哦，我明白了。明白了。好的，酷，酷。太棒了，这真的，真的太棒了。
You know, I knew sort of very vaguely what React.js was all about. But now, sorry, I knew vaguely about React.js, but now I kind of have a deeper understanding of what it's all about. And I actually have a project that I'm doing, that I'm live streaming on Twitch, where I'm just building basically a simple website. And I think we're going to start it with Next.js. So yeah, I actually was going to start last week and then I had some family stuff.
你知道，我有点模糊地知道React.js是关于什么的。但现在，抱歉，我模糊地知道React.js，但现在我有点更深入地了解了它的全部内容。我实际上有一个项目正在做，我在Twitch上直播，我基本上只是在构建一个简单的网站。我想我们将从Next.js开始。所以是的，我实际上打算上周开始，然后我有一些家庭事务。
So I'm going to be starting it this week. And folks out there, I don't know if the episode will be out by next week, but we'll try this with Next.js. And so personally, I'm looking forward to trying this out. So thank you so much for the time. I really appreciate it. And I know the folks out there are going to love it.
所以我这周要开始。外面的朋友们，我不知道这一集下周会不会出来，但我们会用Next.js试试。所以个人而言，我很期待尝试一下。所以非常感谢你的时间。我真的很感激。我知道外面的朋友们会喜欢的。
Thank you. Thank you. Cool. And for everyone out there, thank you again for all of your support and all of the feedback. We've been getting a lot of emails, which is awesome. There's actually some emails from people who are kind of first, second connections to programming language inventors and all of that, which is awesome. There's actually some emails from people who are kind of first, second connections to programming language inventors and all of that, which is awesome. In general, thank you so much for the support. I hope everyone out there is being safe and you're kind of taking
谢谢。谢谢。酷。对于外面的每个人，再次感谢你们所有的支持和所有的反馈。我们收到了很多电子邮件，这太棒了。实际上有一些来自与编程语言发明者有第一、第二联系的人的电子邮件，所有这些都太棒了。实际上有一些来自与编程语言发明者有第一、第二联系的人的电子邮件，所有这些都太棒了。总的来说，非常感谢你们的支持。我希望外面的每个人都平安，你们正在以某种方式采取
this as a time to do some kind of fun side projects and have time at know at home catch you later the intro music is axo by biner pilot programming throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons attribution share alike 2.0 license you're free to share copy distribute transmit the work to to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and share alike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这作为做一些有趣的副项目的时间，并在家里有时间，回头见。介绍音乐是biner pilot的axo。Programming Throwdown是在知识共享署名-相同方式共享2.0许可下分发的。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品以进行重混、改编作品，但你必须向Patrick和我提供署名，并以相同方式共享。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。